the prime minister you have the floor
Madam President, ladies and
gentlemen deputies, madam
President Mathilde Panot
like you like many French people
I was moved and shocked by the death of a
17 year old last week at
Nanterre I also said it to the Senate
very clearly as of last Wednesday the
government has shown the most
great transparency in this matter
and justice will establish all the truth
but Madam President panot in a
time like the one we are going through
yes we have to look at the reality in
face
because for a week in the face of
violence that broke out I'm looking for your
condemnations and I hear excuses
with your part you instrumentalize
a drama you refuse to condemn
clearly the violence you refuse
to call for calm while our
police and our gendarmes fight to
preserve the republican order while
firefighters fight
fires while mothers are at
side of the inhabitants and are the target of
violence from town halls and schools are
burned shops looted elected officials
and their families attacked and you
look for culprits everywhere
all our republican institutions
except among the perpetrators of violence
then you could have as your allies of
the nupasse express your emotion to the
following the death of a 17-year-old
demanded justice and called unambiguously
back to calm but you and the
other rebellious parliamentarians you have
chose another path, that of
the outtrans that of verbal brutality
that of the constant excuse of the
violence
so madam president panot when
your deputies reject all calls for
calm you leave the republican field
when one of your MPs says that the
end justifies the means you get out of
republican field
against your leader talks about driving license
kill for death penalty cops
for young people in the neighborhoods and us
deal with guard dogs you go out
of the republican field
violence Madam President
panel nothing can excuse them and
while you throw oil on the
fire while you give excuses
to the offender we are pledged
to restore republican order and
justice never comes from violence
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much madam
minister the floor is over to Mr.
president marlex
[Applause]
republicans
often put by the hatred of France one
there is chaos in our country in the name
deputies of the republicans i want
express our support for these thousands of
traders whose stores have been
paid i mean our support to these
thousands of French people whose vehicles
were burnt down I mean our
support for the mayor who were taken for
targets and in particular to Vincent Jean Brun
and his family hearing
and I mean our huge
gratitude to the gates of
security
municipal police officers
firefighters I think of the corporal
chief lady the court
their ordinary ex without cold and
the honor of France today alone
a rapid and exemplary criminal response
will stem the violence i will
So ask the Prime Minister
to publish each week the activity of
justice department by department
how many people arrested
how many people referred to the
justice how many people sentenced
time for excuses time for reprieves
the time for impunity is over
for minors our penal code
foresee this is the article
l227-17 that defaulting parents
could be sentenced to prison
or heavy fines when we leave
a kid of 14 or 15 years old outside at 2 a.m.
morning on a night of the packs we must
to have one's responsibility engaged is the
law apply it justice must be
fast and I ask you to mobilize
what will be needed of honorary magistrates
or magistrates on a temporary basis to
judge all his cases within 100
days not to punish would be an insult
for our law enforcement not to punish
it would be not to understand the gravity
of the threat to France would be
prevented for tomorrow from rebuilding the
Concorde in our country it takes a
change of cable it must be radical
I need it now thank you sir
president
the floor is with Madame la Première
minister
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr.
President Olivier Marleix
since unacceptable violence
broke we worked without
release to maintain order
republican throughout the territory with
a will the refusal of impunity
since the beginning of the violence nearly
4,000 people were arrested on
Keeper of the Seals sent a
criminal policy circular
public prosecutor's office asking them for a
firm and systematic rapid response
for all authors and I
confirm Mr President as
we mentioned it yesterday that the guard
seals requires in particular that
criminal penalties may be
pronounced by parents who leave
their children 12 years old 13 years old 14
years take the evening set fire to our
town halls at our police stations
and in total last night nearly 700
people had been referred near
800 custody was in progress the
criminal response is at the rendezvous of
heavy sentences were handed down
including imprisonment with a warrant
deposit already 350 people
are placed in detention, I would add that
the Keeper of the Seals will address within
coming hours a circular on the
dealing with offenses committed by
minors first so that all
reached even at lower intensity
be sanctioned afterwards to put the
parents face their responsibility with
fines for internships
parental responsibility and
taking responsibility for
evasion of their legal obligations
and I would add that we asked the
floor a very specific follow-up of the
violence and too many against
elected officials and we asked the
prosecutor to get in touch with
all victims
but Mr. President Marleix our
desire for a firm penal response from a
justice more efficient faster and
answer more suitable for minors
this is the whole commitment of the government
for six years with, in particular, the
creation in 2021 of a code of justice
criminal law for minors and we will ensure that
its full implementation is also the
meaning of the orientation bill and
program of the Ministry of
Justice that you were currently examining
and I'm thinking of recruiting 10,000
new agents by 2027 for the
Ministry of Justice I am thinking of the
simplification of our criminal procedure
I'm thinking of better compensation
of our victims I am thinking of the extension
work of general interest and I
think also of course of the program of
construction of new buildings
jail by 2027 you debating
in the next few days you see
mr president of marlex us
want a penal response to match
there must be no impunity
we are mobilized thank you thank you
very much Madam Prime Minister
the floor is with Madame Aurore berger
president of the Renaissance group
thank you madam president sunday evening
a 24-year-old man died in
service to protect us from riots
and from its consequences it was called
Dorian in Malincourt and was
firefighters
[Applause]
and sorry to tell you that's all
except off topic dear colleagues because
that since last Tuesday they are good
808 police firefighters and gendarmes who
were hurt to those who shout at
so-called license to kill with our strength
of the order I solemnly say they
have and they deserve our support for
their action
because
the truth my dear colleagues is that
yes the sudden death of a young man this
will always be a drama but it is without
relation to the surge of violence
burn our public school buildings
of the town halls of the libraries drawn
with weapons of war on our
police wait for the lives of our elected officials
and their families to loot businesses
there is no justice in his actions
and when you are a politician
we do not sort out what can
to be burned what cannot be to
those who dared to say that the end
justifies the means to those who have
refuse to call for calm you will be
harshly judged by the French we
must have a speech of truth
obviously for the parents obviously
for our young people who must take
awareness of their actions and
consequences a speech of truth also
against those on the far right
want to make believe that our neighborhoods
would amount to 7000 armed thugs
come to break we tell them
that they are not and that they do not
our neighborhoods because the French who
live in our neighborhoods they are the
first to cry in front of our schools
destroyed they are the first to
suffer damage and these are the
first to respect the rule to respect
the Republic and to love France thank you
very much madam president madam
prime minister what are the actions
that your government will continue to
take to uphold our
Republic
the floor is with Madame la Première
minister
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
gentlemen deputies, madam
President Aurore Bergé a year ago
week to day a young man from
17 year old was killed during a check
road but very quickly after this drama
legitimate emotion has been replaced by
inexcusable violence are first and foremost
the symbols of the Republic and of
theauthority who have been specifically
aimed in particular at town halls, schools
the police stations the brigades of
gendarmerie then there is looting
of stores that burst and in the
night from saturday to sunday violence
went up a notch with the attack of the
residence of the mayor of L'Haÿ-les-Roses and
I have a thought for Vincent again
Jean Brun his wife and children
in the face of this violence our priority
it's the return of the republican order
and our response was based on
four pillars first mobilization
law enforcement with 45,000
police officers in the field
second pillar the firmness of the response
criminal then the responsibility of
social networks and finally a reminder
necessary for responsibility and
parental authority because the authors
are young or even very young we have
we acted with a purpose
no impunity in the face of violence thanks to
to this strong and rapid intervention by
the state thanks to the mobilization of elected officials
local violence began to
decrease from Saturday with a
very sharp decline on Sunday evening and
again last night our objective has
summer and rest to guarantee order
Republican we're on the right
way but we remain extremely
vigilant and its gradually with the
greater caution that we will adapt
our safety device madam
Chair shepherd with the whole
majority with all elected
Republicans we are on the side of
policemen of the gendarmes of the
firefighters we salute the
mobilization of magistrates we are
alongside the seas and the oils of the elect
locals who are on the front line and
we will be present for the
inhabitants for traders
craftsmen for the victims of these
violence like the president of the
Republic has invited us there, we must
also examine all the causes of these
events and as I said yesterday at
all of the group presidents
we will draw all the consequences with
majority groups and all
parliamentarians of the republican arch a
day thank you very much madam the first
minister
the floor is given to Mr. Sébastien Chenu
for the national gathering group
thank you thank you Madam President my
question is addressed to the keepers of the seals
a year ago you told us it will be
Emmanuel Macron or chaos today
it's Emmanuel Macron and the chaos you
told us to live it together
today is to live it with us
want to address us deputies of
national gathering obviously our
acknowledgment our gratitude to
forces of order who everywhere in the
country of municipal police forces
gendarmes passing by the firefighters
national police defended the
French and their property
we want to think of all those French people
those professionals who in the
neighborhoods or in medium-sized towns
were victims we want to tell you
today that nothing is the fruit of
chance all this in reality and the fruit
policies that you have been pursuing for
years that you lead you and your
predecessors but it must be said that
it was the same same same policy
logic even lack of results
your real responsibility is
immense the French expect from
speed expect consistency and
you only give them the opposite since
so many years in 2005 already your speeches
rhymed with sociological analyzes
and with costly tinkering for
the French so today you
surprise you deplore you find that
medium-sized towns like Denain like
lanyard in my constituency either
attacked it burns what symbolizes it
burns France that he hates that of
our memories with the Memorial of the
Shoah Nanterre that of our secularism in
burning schools that of our cultures
with the France of the Enlightenment burning
our theaters it burns our way our
freedom to live what we want
burning the gay bar of Brest yes the
French now refuse your diktat
and your moral intimidations to what
time will you hear our
proposals such as those to come back to
the minority excuse for minors or
family allowances for
families of offenders heard the
about Marine Le Pen who aims to
return their country to the French front
thank you very much the floor is to Mr.
Eric Dupond-Moretti keeps the seals
ministers of justice
Mr President Chenu thank you
first of all not to try to remember
phrases that I never said
and I put you here
respectfully dare to tell me where
and when I pronounced them 2005 I didn't
strictly no responsibility i
weren't in politics you were already
at the UMP
for the rest
for the rest how do you
how do you expect me to answer a
kind of imposium where you mention
both individual freedom and
determines a precise point on which
I can answer you
the minority excuse if you come back to it
I tell you right away that the
Constitutional Council will censure you
Mr DP it is quite clear
because the Constitutional Council
wish we made a difference
between minors and adults and I
think some can find here
for the rest the Ministry of
the Interior and the Ministry of
Justice stood together and they
spread in a republican way to
troubles that have shaken upset our
country
[Applause]
Sir
Boris Vallot group president
socialist
Madam President Madam First
minister a teenager died during
of a police check a teenager
who shouldn't have died and we
say the immense sadness that is the
ours to Naël's family and his
relatives
for the past week, France has experienced
nights of violence in many
cities of all sizes from looting and
destruction of aggression and its acts
we say it are intolerable we
accompanied in the early hours the
calls for a return to civil peace and
respect for public order
we think of all people
police officers firefighters merchants
inhabitants of these neighborhoods to our seas
who have experienced assaults
sometimes fear destruction often and
representative of the nation we must
we stand resolutely sum up alongside
of that
but we know there is no order
without justice that's why will have to come
without waiting for answers
policies a country in which
thousands of young people often
miners go for days and
nights in such facilities is a
country that goes wrong our responsibility
individual collective and watch
face the truth and draw all
the results
ghettoization of some of our
neighborhoods poverty discrimination evil
housing disappearance of services
public failures of our institutions
be so many deep difficulties
including these frequent outbursts of
violence against a minority are also
a symptom it will obviously be necessary
put the Borlo plan back on the job
abandoned to support in the long term the
city ​​policy school
associations and popular education
we owe to the French and to the
French or they live the Republic
everywhere and for everyone finally we must
with serenity and seriousness dealt with the
question of the relationship between a part of the
population and the police who never stopped
deteriorate like we can't
ignore the question of use either
weapons, that is to say the evulation of
the law that we demand, Madam
prime minister we cannot
understand this excuse it is not
excused to understand is to act in the
justice and peace than when we close the
first
minister you have the floor
[Applause]
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
Boris Vallaud
first of all i would like to thank you
because you condemned without ambiguity
the violence that affected
many municipalities and called to the
civil peace unlike your
rebellious allies
and Mr President vano I hear
your questions about the roots of
crisis and the responses we can
bring in particular through the
city ​​policy this reflection of
longer term it will take place but I
can tell you that we don't have
ceased to act for the neighborhoods and for
city ​​policy for 6 years
since 2017 we have increased the
budget of the National Agency for
urban renewal increased to 12 billion
euros we have implemented the
educational cities we have split the
CP and CE1 classes and deploy
100,000 free jobs for the benefit of
inhabitants of the neighborhoods so yes we
we need to do some in-depth thinking
on the shores of this crisis with all
arc political groups
republican in these moments our
responsibility is listening to
proposals from elected officials, in particular from elected officials
of land is also assumed
collectively the complexity of the subject
and build effective responses
with everyone and this is particularly the meaning
of the exchange that the President of the
Republic has at this very moment with almost
of 300 meters in the communes have been
affected by violence like us
we had the opportunity to talk about it yesterday
Mr President we are still
mobilized and focused on the return of
republican order and reparation
but I assure you sir
President Vallot we are determined
to continue to act for the galaxies
our public services and for equality
chances especially our territory i
thank you thank you very much madam
Prime Minister
the floor is with Madame Cyrielle
castellan president of the group
environmentalist
thank you madam president madam
Prime Minister, dear colleagues of
Marseille to Héricourt de Montargis to
Lyon from Échirolles to Nanterre in all
the abandoned territories of the cities
in the countryside the revolt tore the
France because it has been 18 years since
policies fail 18 years since the
death of Ziad Bena and Bouna Traoré and
today it is Naël who is killed
18 years of sterility
rationalization and disappearance of
public services for 18 years
which the Republican contract was
please flout because reality
Madam Prime Minister is that in
France today some lives are worth
less than others certain territories
are worth less than others
equality is a theoretical concept
burning schools looted from stores
assaulted of the elect will never be
acts of justice violence cannot
not be the solution that's why we
ecologists we members of the nupesse
we did not resign ourselves to a world where
some have it all and some don't
nothing there is no fatality our is
responsibility is to have an answer
politics first the act of appeasement
announce the modification of the law of
2017 announce the return of the police from
proximity and put in place
immediate control measures
against discrimination and against
racism then humility
policies can never succeed
alone listen to the officials
field associations the seas and
parents not just two hours in
period of crisis but all year round and
finally invest in youth
we need a real policy of
youth and go to public school
a priority without a school that
does not work the quality madam
prime minister when will you stop
to be petrified and will you understand
finally strong measures to recreate and
repair and recreate the links you
let it fall apart
[Music]
the speech
the floor is to Madam the first
minute
ladies and gentlemen deputies madam
President Cyrielle Châtelain you
called him back a week ago
drama of the death of a young man of 17
years during a roadside check
many shocked across our country
in the face of this tragedy the rapes the responses
will come from justice and not from
violence and you said it yourself
yet for a week
unacceptable violence broke out
in some municipalities this violence
you condemned them and I want
salute this republican attitude which
contrasts with that of some of your
allies but Madam President
Chatelain is violence have nothing to do
see with a revolt of the suburbs and
I was Madam President of the chatelain
in Nanterre in Garges-lès-Gonesse in Bezons
in Évry in L'Haÿ-les-Roses I exchanged
with elected officials and residents and two
words keep coming back
misunderstanding and anger anger
vis-à-vis its perpetrators of violence who
quite a few of the policies carried out for
years all the efforts that have been
facts for city politics
especially in the previous five-year period
to renovate its neighborhoods
rebuild public facilities
to strengthen access to public service
in these neighborhoods and vis-à-vis the
youth Madam President Chatelain
we acted throughout the president
previous five-year period we acted
throughout the previous five-year period
with the development of learning
with frank jobs with today
the reform of the vocational high school therefore
Madam President Chatelain, it is
violence are inexcusable they do not
not represent the youth of our
countries we support all French people
all young people in all in all
the territories of our Republic i
thank you
thank you very much madam
minister
the floor is over to Mr. Jean-Paul
Mattei President of the Democratic Group
thank you madam president madam
Prime Minister last Tuesday a drama
happened with the death of young Naël
oar for which there is still time
of mourning it is also the time of
justice that must take its course in
respect for the principles of the State of
right
from entire neighborhoods in our
metropolises as in our territories
more than 5,000 vehicles are set on fire
burnt 1000 buildings burnt degraded
or looted hundreds of town halls
public services at the attacked police station
these abuses must be condemned
all kinds because they destroy
common goods they destroy
entire families and experts from
many actors who are every day
on the ground the State responded
quickly and vigorously both by the
number of police forces mobilized
that by actions justice very
quickly implemented I want
moreover salute here the courage and the
cold blood of the police of the gendarmes
that of the firefighters of course
but I also want to greet the seas
servant of the Republic who have been
at the front day and night since Tuesday they
are at the center of all action they are
often victims of attacks and even
now it is their families who
are on the front line that is
unacceptable
without them our Republic is nothing or
very few things and I know they have
never mind free they are they have to
their side all the volunteers of their
municipal council the teaching staff
and the associative world throughout my
model democrat group and independents
I want to pay tribute
today to the mayor and you ask
Madam Prime Minister of their
report all support in the
government is capable it must
urgently give them the means to
rebuild media libraries schools
the police stations all these places
which make up the heart of our territory and
which gives meaning to the words communicated
community
thank you very much Mr President
the floor is with Madame la Première
minister
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr.
President Jean-Paul Mattei the episodes
violence in recent days
are now experiencing a decline
important but I do not forget the
damage caused they are town halls of
schools of the police stations of the brigades of
police station gendarmerie
municipal and public buildings
vandalized and sometimes burned these are
shops tobacconists
ransacked and looted they are cars
burned it is unacceptable and I
say that we are with all
victims of violence from
damage or looting and I
affirms it before you, we will ensure
what local authorities
wish to be accompanied and can
quickly restore
damaged equipment procedures
will be lightened and deadlines reduced to
maximum and the State will support
when it is necessary it is
precisely at this very moment
President of the Republic exchange on
these matters with seas and we
we will provide all the answers to these
mothers so that they can as soon as possible
recommission their equipment
public and we will also be at
alongside the inhabitants of the traders of the
craftsmen of affected traders
may in particular benefit from deferrals
tax and social charges the most
affected will even be able to benefit from a
cancellation of these charges and of course
we ask for the mobilization of
insurers of which it is primarily the
responsibility the Minister of the Economy
Bruno Le Maire met them on Saturday
last and yesterday again the insurers
mobilize they are committed to everything
to make life easier for victims
of violence by extending the deadlines for
declaration of loss by accelerating
their compensation and reducing the
deductibles on a case-by-case basis see sir
President Mattei we want
rebuild quickly and we will be at
alongside the elected traders of the
craftsmen and all the victims of
violence thank you thank you
very much Madam Prime Minister
I call Mr Stéphane little for
the GDR group
thank you madam president my question
addresses the Prime Minister in
its vast majority the country said its
indignation at the death of young Naël
and since Wednesday I haven't stopped
come across people angry at the
violence and destruction
unacceptable the hour must be at
appeasement but calls for unity
and firmness won't be enough either
essential it is it will not be necessary
look away once the calm
income I first want here to restore a
truth no there is no territory
lost of the Republic there is
there are only territories that the
Republic gives up
Thus
sitting since 2005
since 2005 except for the renovation
urban all these degraded in particular
school
who should be the apple of our eye
and which public service is the most
mistreated the school is mistreated because the
resources allocated through the
city ​​policy does not compensate
never weakening policies
of common rights abused because in the
secondary it would take 45,000 people
more to find the rate
framing of 2006 gold in 6 years you
have cut 8900 jobs
abused when in the academy of
Créteil listen to me well we admit to
teacher competition with a mark of
4 out of 20 while the threshold is 14
out of 20 in the rest of France and
that in addition we are preparing to provide the
positions by recruitment on leboncoin
or by jobs dating this is this is not
not that the school of the Republic Mr.
Minister we still believe in the word
of Victor Hugo according to which when one
open a school we close a prison we
believe that the school is a part of the
commission my question what extent
do you hear
thank you very much time is running out
exceeded the floor is over to Mr. Pope
Ndiaye Minister of National Education
and youth
[Applause]
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
Stéphane little no the Republic
don't give up any territory education
national does not abandon any territory
she does not abandon the girls and the
daughters of the Republic in the
department that you
quote the Saint-Denis scene the means
teaching to them even as the
school population will drop
notably next year the means
education remain at the same level
and Mr. Deputy, that's why
that we increase
can you have some respect
first for teachers including
contract teachers on the one hand
let me express myself
a little calm a little calm sir
Minister, you have the floor that we
let's stage Saint-Denis
particularly it was
it was Mr. Deputy
splitting the splitting of classes
of CP of C1 of large sections it was
the learning camps were the 12
educational cities that were created these
last years these are means
additional teaching
soon the opening of very small
sections is also also the
school and extracurricular timetables
extended from 8 a.m. until 6 p.m.
it is also at the start of the 2024 school year
scholarships that will be paid
automatically without people
have to go claim it's finally a plan
for the 40 fastest growing colleges
difficulty on the 130 yes that you
not interested in my answer and well I
gives it to you because I'm interested in
Seine-Saint-Denis and I don't do it
a political argument
sir thank you very much
Mr minister
[Applause]
go a little silence the floor is up
Mr. Bertrand Penchère Chairman of the
lion group
with all the members of the group
liote I wanted to support the
traders to the security forces of
relief and to the inhabitants who have been
affected by the violence in our country
obviously to the youngster's family we
condemn all this violence without
reserve nothing can justify
destruction and looting it is one thing
however that I have learned from my mandates
local public action calls
humility I have heard analyzes of
politically irresponsible pseudo-experts
fueling hate speech there
there is no miracle solution there is one
emergency the return to calm but then
then a construction site that must no longer be
buried that of a policy of
social cohesion we cannot treat
separately the security issues of
criminal responses to discrimination
access to health employment or
of education everything is linked you have to take
all these words at the root
propose solutions adapted to our
territories I wanted Borlo report
worked with 200 m and associations
there was a report the immobilist to
immobility would create a new
crisis we are there there were
many concrete answers for a
national reconciliation unfortunately
it was certainly a missed appointment
things have been done but so little we
have a fear that the solutions
partial measures are put in place and that
we moved on and only one
another crisis arises on the contrary
need global solutions forged with
elected officials association leaders
police mediators education
national we called it a
council of the wise it is therefore appropriate to
resume the Borlo report, Madame la
Prime Minister of the updated the
values ​​of our Republic cannot
progress only if the promise of equality
possible my question is simple as
will we finally build a destiny
common giving hope to our
fellow citizens is President Macron there
ready by associating all the forces
Long live our country and finally
rebuild a more humane world
just more fraternal thank you very much
Mr President, the floor is
Madam Prime Minister
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr.
President Bertrand lean allow me
first of all to thank you for your
profoundly republican attitude and
unambiguous in the face of violence
unacceptable that took place these
last days in these moments it is
essential that all elected officials attached to
values ​​of the Republic continues
[Music]
to speak
yes you have a problem when i speak
elected officials attached to the values ​​of
Republic ladies and gentlemen
deputies
So I tried to all the elect
attached to the values ​​of the Republic
continue to speak with one voice in
a republican spirit to denounce the
violence the attacks a qualifiable
to elected officials and to support our police officers
our police and firefighters
so like you I know that the return
calm will not solve everything but it
is the essential prerequisite for any
long-term action
will then come the time for the debates of
bottom
but I want to tell you that for six
years we have not stopped working to
the city policy you mention
Jean-Louis Borloo's report
are right to do so and we have
taken over many of his
proposals we have confirmed
the National Agency for Renovation
urban by increasing considerably
its budget we made
education and youth
pillars of city policy i
think in particular of the educational cities that
we have created to fight against
inequalities of destiny and better structure
community actors on the ground
educational I am thinking of the duplication of
CP and CE1 classes that we were
to large sections and it is not
everything we acted for employment and if
the unemployment rate is still too high
in our neighborhoods it has dropped by 5
points since 2017 so Mr.
President leaning we are
determined to work and act for our
neighborhoods for all our territories and
we will do it for all the elect
committed to the unity of our country I
thank you thank you very much madam
Prime Minister
the floor is over to Mr. Laurent Marc
Angeli president of the horizon group thank you
Madam President Madam First
minister our country has been through these last
days dreadful hours nothing nothing
cannot justify attacking
schools to libraries to premises
associations that work for the good
common our fellow citizens see their
burned cars of traders their
store looted from elected police officers and
sometimes even simple passers-by who
find in the wrong place in the wrong
moment are savagely attacked i
would already like to salute on behalf of the
horizon group and parent work
exceptional achievement by our forces of
relief and security they often have
been mobilized in territories that
were not theirs in the
extremely difficult conditions that
we all know
we would also like to pay tribute to
the unfailing commitment of which
proof of our elected officials who refuse
to retreat in the face of threats and
assaults my dear colleagues there is
no social demands to be found
in these unacceptable actions
no legitimate anger no excuses
but only an act of acts of
Secession of a minority which rejects
any form of authority these rejections of
order Republicans are made at the
detriment of tens of millions of
French who have only one desire
a single request that of a manager
peaceful life for them and for their
family how else not to be
taken aback by the young age of
individuals arrested what are these
minors alone sometimes all night in
the street where their titular parents are
of parental authority and responsible for
ensure both their education and their
security that monitors the attitude and
the activity of these young people on the networks
social and online
Madam Prime Minister our
ability to make a nation and seriously
threatened by these recent events
how do you intend to reaffirm
the authority of the state and the primacy of
republican pact against individuals
who seems ready to do anything to make reign
chaos thank you very much sir
President, the floor is given to Madam
Prime Minister
[Applause]
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr.
President Laurent Marc Angeli you have
reason to say the violence of these
last few days are unacceptable and I
again want to pay tribute to our
police our gendarmes our
firefighters whose courage is
exceptional in the face of the violence of these
last days
our priority is to guarantee the
return to calm and ensure safety
of all French people and as the
President of the Republic we must
also engage in reflection on the
root causes of this situation and
the national representation it will take
naturally all its part us
will examine all the subjects without
exception without taboos or pretense
we must in particular ensure respect
authority in general and
the exercise of parental authority
we need to better regulate social networks
and you will have the opportunity to examine
soon a text aimed at better
secure and regulate the digital space
and as the President of the
Republic we must strengthen our
answers by punishing young people as soon as
the first gap with you sir
President Marc Angeli with the ensemble
majority deputies with all
those who want to build
solutions
refuse caricatures and ideas
all done our goal is
efficiency in the answers are
solutions for the inhabitants of
neighborhoods for the inhabitants of all our
territories and for our youth our
ambition is the unity of the Republic
thank you thank you very much madam
the prime minister
the floor is over to Mr. Michael tavern
for the national rally
thank you madam president of the tens
of years of Ermont of ideology even of
submission these are the causes of the
dramatic situation affecting our
country all those who succeeded each other in
power carries a share of
responsibilities in this chaos
remember Emmanuel Macron had
explained it would be him or chaos
it is, however, his policy that has
lying down from the chaos we know
today my question will be about
the security aspect of this chaos and
addressed to Ministers of the Interior
the tragic event in Nanterre and the
ensuing riots throughout the
countries have once again demonstrated to
eyes of millions of French people that everything
was a pretext to destroy, set on fire and
loot unsustainable images showing
schools media libraries crèches
transport town hall vehicles
in common go up in smoke condemning
thus the inhabitants of the neighborhoods and the
honest people who are the first
victims to live in fear and
chaos
the security chaos that has affected
our whole country fits well
sure in the case of the migrants that we
suffer and against which you stand
arms dangling despite our alerts
for years the government
continue the policy of the ostrich and
this reality comes back to you in full
figure yourself minister
you seem to overtake and disconnect
by affirming that on the night of
friday to saturday the intensity is witness
when it was the worst
visionary and I'm not talking about the
stomping on the highest peak in the state
of the presumption of innocence of the person
who served the Republic under
police uniform
in the face of this barbaric predators who
parade state authority spit on
France and violent elected officials designed
on this safe to support the
law enforcement in their mission to
when this on this policy to evict
Foreign offenders Mr.
minister what do you intend to do for this
security chaos ceases and that
the authority of the state is finally restored
in our country
thank you very much the floor is to Mr.
Gérald Darmanin Minister of the Interior
and overseas
Madam President and gentlemen
MPs Mr. Deputy
following the tragic events of
Nanterre where I believe as the first
Minister I was able to express myself to say in
effect that all justice the truth
must be done respecting the
presumption of innocence which is due to
all citizens and therefore including
law enforcement I mean here
first my support for the 808 police
gendarmes and firefighters injured and
obviously to this master corporal
of the fire brigade of
Paris
I believe, sir, that in a
such a terrible time for our country
it should not
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to remember sir
that the Republic is a balance yes
order and firmness
yes the right order but not just the order
yes you have to listen, sir
the police the gendarmes who
work hard in all
Republic neighborhoods and I am I
believe the first and support yes
Mr. Deputy, it is also necessary not to
confuse debates less than 10% of
4,000 arrested were foreigners
Mr. Deputy 90% were French
Only 40 people were eligible
an administrative detention center
today's question is what
young offenders not strangers
there are many of us here Mr.
MP be from the neighborhoods to be
with an immigrant background and to love our
country and we don't want hatred
of the police nor of the hatred of
strangers but we want love
of the Republic
thank you very much sir
tavern the contempt that characterizes you
reveals your
incompetence the only one who will answer the
security problem is Marine Le Pen
the only one who will set up a
politician Marine Le Pen or than ever
the speech
the floor is over to Mr. Alexandre
vincended for the group
republican thank you madam president
my question is for madam
Prime Minister as Member of Parliament
the 7th district of the Rhône with
in particular the towns of Rillieux-la-Pape
Bron and Vaulx-en-Velin I've been like
many others in this show at
heart of the chaos of the last few days
Madam Prime Minister my question
is double our police security forces
national gendarmerie municipal police
and firefighters were heroic
Republic must be grateful to them
remind parents of their responsibility
also been salutary the Republic
it's rights and duties
understood for the parents and it is
urgent to draw all the
consequences
while the thugs are the object of
lawsuits what do you intend to do to
against proxy rioters
those who refused to call for calm
those who by dint of excusing everything
permanence in the middle of the oil on the
fire even if it means denying himself as Mr.
Mélenchon who in 2012 castigated the
hordes of thugs calling them
jester and minion cretins of the
capitalist society today
incites violence by selecting
for them the informed targets the calls to
sedition by public officials
and policies are intolerable
the second part of my question madam
the Prime Minister concerns the
city ​​policy and he mother of
Rillieux-la-Pape in 2014 we have
initiated an urban renewal plan
unprecedented the money is there the
problem is that the procedures are
too long the action time is too long
long and between times the decisions
taken in 2014 the first effects are not
are felt only 10 or even 20
years later it's a long so long and
complex that it becomes unreadable for
our fellow citizens who live like me
in these neighborhoods which for the immense
majority of them do everything for
live with dignity and respect for
the Republic that discredits the
public speech and leave the field open
thug and to those who
also instrumentalize Madame la
Prime Minister what do you plan to do
to help mayors speed up
stronger and more effectively I
thank you thank you very much
Steph Béchu Minister of Transition
environment and the cohesion of
territories
Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
vincent of
This morning
at the Elysée more than 200 m from any
political sensitivities of all sizes
of communes were also around the
President of the Republic to share
their distress their observation
and to hear including in what
use this moment which should be a
moment of dignity to launch
sentences on the fly at the two extremes of
this hemicycle I am sorry because
the first support we owe them
to bring is that of evoking these
subjects with a minimum of respect
cannot at the same time greet the
officials salute the forces of
the order salutes the elect and when we
evokes and that a question is asked about the
way to support them
kind of use shortcuts or do
so as to push his own ideology
without taking the time
to hear what they have to say and what
who is this reality then these mothers
what do they say they say it
there are red tape they
say we have to make sure not
throw city politics with
bath water and who has success stories
tens of billions of euros which have
been invested have allowed in a certain
number of places to allow
successes and that at the same time
it's not because we have these images that
are terrible that we must conceal
the stories and journeys that may have
be
the problem is that when a family
gets out who replaces her a family
which is again and among the most
fragile and able to look
this reality in front of these measure
the magnitude of the fight for diversity
will win if we're all together and I
want to join you on the silences
indecent
of Mélenchon's extreme left because
that it is these silences that have
contributed to setting fire to the powder and
I tell you in these neighborhoods
people deserve more than you
treat like rioters in
power your class contempt for
the inhabitants of the popular district
bursts in the way you
instrumentalize
[Music]
the floor is over to Mr. Sacha Houlier
from the Renaissance group thank you madam
President, my question is for
Mr. Eric Dupond-Moretti keeps
seals Mr. Keeper of the Seals these
last days everywhere in France
major riots followed the death
of Naël I want of course here to repeat my
support for his family an investigation of
the IGPN has been opened and justice is
seize this drama as serious as it is
can be used on the pretext of the fire that
we have noted I welcome in this regard
the responsible attitude of the majority
elected officials who have called for calm
the notable exception of a quarter round
how about a huskule group of places
who has permanently discredited himself I
speaks of course of insubordinate France
but that is what our fellow citizens are waiting for
today it's accuracy in the
pronounce justice Mr.
keeps seals in less than a week
the police carried out more
of 3,000 arrests, the defendants
been brought before the courts and
we are subject to the procedure of
immediate appearance given the
seriousness of the facts can you tell us
know the instructions you have
given to the prosecutor so that they are
intractable in their requisition
can you tell us if these
requests were followed by
magistrates they let us know the
nature of the sentences imposed on the
rioters can you tell us if we
have enough magistrates
to judge his massive facts and we
insure contrary to the old lies
of the extreme right that these sentences
will be well applied as the sound 95%
sentences handed down
Mr. Keeper of the Seals
emotes are young often minors
sometimes they are 17, others 14 or
even 12 you asked the question
of parental authority you were right
parental mediation in
working-class neighborhoods will deserve this
small in this capacity to be reinforced but
in the meantime what instructions
have you given to ensure that the
parents do not leave their
son finally as the president of the
Republic you pointed the
social media responsibility
behind the screens too many young people or
less young by the way I think
superhuman untouchables
to say anything stirs up anger
calls for hatred we can no longer
time of responsibility sir
Keeper of the seals we want to know
how you will implement the
promise to unmask the rioters who
hide behind their phone
how to identify them refer them
above all, delete without delay the
unbearable contents that they hesitate
Thanks a lot
party Keeper of the Seals Minister of
justice
ladies and gentlemen deputies sir
President Houlier first of all I share
what you say the emotion we
owe the death of this young man to his
family but in nothing I say well in nothing
it cannot justify the looting and
the looting and exactions to which
we attended so yes soon
Friday I took a circular from
general policy intention of
attorneys general attorneys and
prosecutor of our country I would have asked
the firmness of the reactivity and I
must say the ink of the circular
was barely dry than already the
prosecutors was implementing it and I
here solemnly want to return it
tribute because they were at
appointment
at the appointment of Justice of the same
way I want to pay homage to the
sitting magistrate to the clerk who
for hours and hours
responded
have spread to these abuses
unbearable and that's what we
did first I asked the
attorney he requires and that is
possible since 2021 with the networks
social media so that we find the names and
the addresses of course
users there is not a kid who
can and who should still think
today that he can escape his
responsibility then responsibility
parents there are parents
do you see
there are parents you see who are
able to exercise authority
parental and who does not exercise it
being 12 years old on the street is not
normal and I just set up
in another circular a certain
number
a number of guidelines for
We remind all parents
the obligations that are theirs finally
naturally justice was at the
appointment of the firmness that I learned
of my wishes 350 incarcerations have been
pronounced that's what I meant
but we need justice
justice thank you
the floor is over to Mr. Antoine léoman
for the group la France insoumise
if Madam President Mr
Darmanin this Friday the unions
factious alliance and a sapolis are
threatened the executive power in a
communicated after threatening the
legislative and judicial powers
it's a new milestone that has been crossed
when will you remind alliance that the
police are not there to give
orders but to serve and obey the
truth is that you are paralyzed by
fear you're afraid to end up like
Mr. Castaner sacked in 48 hours
for denouncing the keys
of strangulation you are afraid to close
the kitty of shame launched by a
racist to reward the murderer of
Naël you are afraid that the police will
turns against you after having it
used to force through your
pension reform is what
happens when you put authority to rest
of the state not on membership but on the
repression this fear paralyzes your
action this fear and the one that
prevents action when the UN denounces the
racism in the police but you are not there
this racism is president macronise
of the Assembly says that the police exercise
his mission in a marvelous way
name of Tahiti Gabriel Samy who lives
gangali Mohamed so young of my
riding aged 13 to 17 i
want to talk to you about this marvel
shut your mouth dog face you want
[ __ ] you or what are these words
those of policemen to these young people he
shocks you so much the better perhaps that
you will react the code of ethics
says the policeman must behave
in an exemplary way that inspires
in return respect and consideration
do you think these insults inspire
respect and consideration do you think that
when these police unions by the
out of wild pests and
war they employ something other than a
racist vocabulary because war is
against an enemy within
does not exist in a republic of enemies of
inside
racism is a delight and the poison of
the Republic when are you going to sack
is to punish racist police officers who
soil their colleague's uniform
republicans when are you going to
justice to young people as a Tahitian who
sums up their attachment to the
Republic by a simple phrase we are
all French we must have the same
rights thank you very much
[Music]
the floor is given to Mr. Gérald Darmanin
Minister of the Interior and Overseas
[Applause]
[Music]
go a little silence sir
minister you have the floor
Thank you, Madam President, Mr.
Deputy, we must not confuse everything one
policeman drawn up in review every
police were not charged
offenders from certain neighborhoods
put a bag of the cities every
residents of the neighborhoods did not update
bag the cities
police unions and put
releases no sir the deputy the
Minister of the Interior does not correct any
release of no union that come
of FO of the CGT or alliance
a kitty has been opened it must be
close no sir he
belongs like during vests
yellow as during the bombings
justice of our country and in particular
high court of power
close this pot
deputy
make the sentence of Jacques Brel lie
you are not indeed
revolutionaries you are small
revolted be at the rendezvous of the
Republic
thanks a lot Madam
[Applause]
the floor is with Mrs Marine Christmas
Baptist for the Socialist Group
[Music]
SO
my dear colleagues you have just asked
a question please listen to the question
next madam baptistel you have the
word thank you Madam President my
question is addressed to the Minister of
health and prevention question after
question parliamentarians on all sides
bring you back every week
concerns of our fellow citizens about
access to healthcare in hospital
countryside or in town the same observations
deficiency are drawn let me
today to get your attention
on access to gynecological care
medical which is stricken in our
countries and even impossible in 13
departments as recently noted
DDF Senate report lacks
eyelashes specialist insufficient treatment
obstetric violence and
gynecological uneven coverage of the
territory are all subjects that
primarily affect women and
which concerns all of us here
both the consequences and this sustainability
scarcity generates its multiple of a point
from a health and social point of view between 2020 and
2020 France has experienced a decline since
50% of its staff of gynecologists
medical professionals
parliamentary feminist association
recognition of the need to go further
far faster and to plan a
significant increase in the number
interns in this specialty
deficit if we do nothing
will get worse, we are already seeing
negative consequences for many
fans of late tracking absences
proven in the diagnoses and in the end
lose chance our amendment
transpartisan regulation at
installation could have been a start
answer to the problem of desires
doctors in all disciplines
You refused, Mr.
Minister allow support
effective female gynecological
contributes to their emancipation then
can you tell us if you are going
agree to open more positions
of intern in medical gynecology in
the framework of the class exam in National
to enter 2023 how do you plan
sustainably rebuild the workforce
of this profession while on the horizon
2030 we could still lose 20% of
our specialists and finally do you envisage
to increase the skills framework of
prescribing midwives
by the extension of the decree of March 5, 2022
thank you thank you very much my dear
colleague the floor is with François Brown
minister of health and prevention
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Madam Deputy
Baptiste the lack of professional
health is a real challenge for our
health system this lack of
health professional unfortunately
whatever specialties you
talk about medical gynecology but
it is also the other specialties and
all the same the result of a few
decades of management totally
blind medical staff and
paramedics so we removed
the numerus clausus we now have
more than 15% of students who are
accepted in second year of medicine
we have also strengthened training
in nursing in connection with the regions
more than 6000 training positions
of nurses over 3,000 nursing positions
nurse's aide training we have
also a major issue on these
nurses is abandonment for 10%
antenna of studies that is why
we have just launched a reform
complete trade and training
nurse to keep them in the
territories and in training in this
Concerning
the answers we can provide
beyond these figures which will not form
doctors only in 10 years and well
the major challenge is to give back time
medical give back medical time to
professionals is to remove them
all tasks that are unnecessary
any case for which they do not have
of added value is the case of the plan taken
in February on the 15 useless Stach
it is also to promote the exercise
multi-professional to return and
coordinate of course to come back to
what you said about the
midwives and gynecologists
medical and indeed the widening of
midwifery skills also allows
immediately to provide an answer to the
level of the territories where we lack
gynecologist and then beyond that
knowledge sharing exercise
coordinated by help by assistants
medical helps to increase, as we know
already 10%, potential patients
treated by a doctor without
work more so you see there is
responses on two levels there are
answers to increase the number of
professionals whatever he is in
all specialties and gynecology
medical like gynecology
obstetrics will benefit the same
way and also give back more
professional time to the doctor for
that it can support more than
patients
thank you madam president my question
addresses Gérald Darmanin Minister of
Interior and Overseas
I don't blame the police but
only to one person he who took away
life to my son here are the words
pronounced by Naël's mother these words
have found an answer with our
justice because yes the policeman
the man in question was actually
charged with intentional homicide
and place under temporary tension
he will have to answer for his of his of his
acts and this is moreover what
recalled the President of the Republic the
Prime Minister the Keeper of the Seals and
yourself minister because
yes and it may have you
displease but we are in a state of
right and that's how we
operate under the rule of law
this rule of law which unfortunately
for a year a year has been suffering from amalgams
false exaggeration of a party
of the benches of this hemicycle which
prefer to curl up in
polemics rather than making
politics and yes I am talking about you
ladies and gentlemen of France
rebellious don't mind us
we will continue to rise to stand up
so that our Republic continues
to exist and defend its values ​​and
we don't do it alone we don't do it
do we do it through action
the resolute action of these women and its
men who in the field on a daily basis
continue to protect us and ensure
our safety, of course, I'm talking about
of our strong order then sir
the Minister of the Interior and
Overseas the question is simple how
please how deal with this heckling
this chaos wanted by some have you
still to find the words to reassure
these men and women these committed
daily so that they do not resign
that he does not give up that he does not despair
not because yes part of the
national representation today
prefer to point fingers at risk
to threaten them thank you very much my dear
colleague, the floor is over to Gérald Darmanin
Minister of the Interior and Overseas
thank you thank you Madam President
Ladies and gentlemen deputies madam
the deputy
the 250,000 police and gendarmerie
could with the Minister of Accounts
public add customs officers plus
municipal police do a job
extremely difficult and we all know it
demanding dangerous they are the girls
and the daughters of the people who spend
contest undergo training are
particularly watched by their
hierarchy particularly watch
as having responsibilities and are
so in this respect and it is quite
normal for the sake of ethics
of requirement and when it does not respect the
Republic when it does not respect its
ethical probity requirements they
are sanctioned they are among the
most scrutinized public officials such as
I already wanted to say it's not madam
the deputy because there is an uproar
because there is husk at and because
political politics that we must
distinguish the dead the drama of
Nanterre
the whole nation mourns him I think too
to Mélanie Lemay this policeman from
Lot-et-Garonne killed by a refusal to
temper at 26
I am also thinking of Romain boulange this
young policeman from the district of
the island that leaves a 7-year-old orphan
in the courtyard of the police station because
that a driver did not stop
ladies and gentlemen, we do not
must not reject the dead of a camp
to another we must respect the rules
of the Republic for all citizens
whether or not they are police and I want
say here that there are no bands
rivals there are no police and
the thugs there is only the Republic
who must speak to all citizens without
ten religion race instinct and
of beliefs and there should be
political unanimity to fight those
who set fire to the schools and who
bourg will say, however, about the forces of
the order
[Applause]
[Music]
the floor is over to Mr. Benjamin Lucas
for the environmental group
thank you madam president
Malik or who is it
Fabrice Fernandez ZZ
Luigi du Kennet Rémi Fraisse Adama
Traore Abubakar Fofana Zineb Redouane
Steve Maya caniso Cédric chouvia Mohamed
Gapsi Camara Naël
it's no these are screws torn from the
bereaved families in cities
bruised by a traumatic memory
that bad weather ever when you
deny the reality of police violence
or face checks you refuse
to cast a lucid gaze that which
must have a great democracy like
ours on the real so that the
same causes do not produce the same
effects will you finally recognize the
reality madam prime minister
put citizens around the table
local elected officials associations
educators police officers
and finally study the proposals for
establish a bond of trust between all
the population and the republican police
Thank you
the floor is given to Mr. Gérald Darmanin
Minister of the Interior and Overseas
the president sir deputy sir
the deputy who needs to be improved without
stop the work of public officials and
especially law enforcement
it's obvious it's this majority
you didn't vote that rose
of 4 months the training of the guards of
peace it was necessary to increase the
training peacekeepers suddenly
sure it's that majority and you don't
you did not vote that increased by 50% the
continuous training of police officers is
this majority and you don't have it
voted that put in law only when
a policeman or a gendarme was
responsible for domestic violence or
had trafficked condemned by justice
or make xenophobic racist remarks
or homophobic should be excluded from the
civil service and you don't have it
voted sir be
constructive help us also be so
you want I heard just now
Honest President Vallot is the
socialist majority which passed the law of
February 2017 is the majority
socialist
who in difficult circumstances
realized that the police
gendarmes because at the time there were
no doubt a republican left which
was in charge owed their
to be able to face every day
those who wanted to kill cops and what
is the report when they don't respect
not the law of the Republic when he
obviously not respecting
donutology that must be thrown to the dogs
all the other police officers in France
law change report
in emotion when it's a policeman
who was at fault told you you say without
doubt every day that it is necessary to stop
to legislate this cost of emotion that
applies to all citizens including
for the police, sir
[Applause]
Minister of the Interior
it is precisely because we want
accompany police officers
that we point your responsibility
those of successive governments
that of political leaders in
a law enforcement organization
and police operations that
led to more deaths than elsewhere in
Europe which is a problem today
systemic can you deny can you
deny in my constituency to
Mantes-la-Jolie where 150 high school students were
parked hands on head filmed
by law enforcement with this
sentence Here is a class that is held
wise that there is no violence
policewoman can you tell a
young who is controlled 7 or 10 times more
than another because of the color of
its skin that there is no control
discriminatory Minister of
the Interior an adult democracy it
puts all the problems on the table and
she confronts them with an open gaze with
awareness of reality numbers
journalistic investigations and
sociological surveys she does not do
of a Trump thank you Minister
[Applause]
Mister deputy yes I listen to the
residents and elected officials, for example
Mantes-la-Jolie where I went where
the mayor asks-the-pretty in your
constituency calls for more
policemen yes mr deputy me me
who was also of a popular life
I know it's above all
residents of working-class neighborhoods
need security and to deny it is
let the inhabitants of the neighborhood
popular vote national rally
while they've been left since
very long thank you very much sir
minister
the floor is over to Mr. Thomas arranged
for the national rally
thank you from the president like those who
preceded them Emmanuel Macron and his
government are once again doing the
terrible demonstration of their
total inability to protect
French of the chaos that hit our
country I remember the words of the
candidate Emmanuel Macron who explained
that it would be him or chaos it is
nevertheless its policy which has
birthed the chaos we know
today my question will be about
the economic aspect of this chaos and
is addressed to the ministers of the economy and
finances on Thursday night at
Friday the town of Montargis where I
am elected was the victim of real
scenes of war in this town of
14,000 inhabitants yet spared by
the swords by the 2005 riots three
buildings were destroyed ravaged by
the flames 80 businesses vandalized and
plundered by hordes of young people
scum no longer any territory is
therefore now sheltered from the ENS
wildly in Montargis as in
many small towns it's all one
commercial fabric which is today
stopping in an economic context
difficult after the health crisis and
as inflation explodes
traders need measurements well
more ambitious than the postponement announcement
charge and the diligence of the
insurances and banks they wait
strong measures to see each other
compensate for losses related to periods
where they were forced to close for
their safety but above all the losses
related to the decline in attendance at
medium term which affects all
traders in the city centers concerned
Minister, our merchants have
fed up they are angry understand
their fed up their fed up with those
who get up early to go to work
who bring our town centers to life and who
saw their working tool destroyed in
one night by young savages their
fed up with those who finance by
their work with their taxes the aids
benefits from which some benefit
parents of these thugs Mr.
minister what do you intend to do for
come to the aid of traders and avoid
this new economic chaos in our
territories thank you very much sir
deputies the floor is over to Mr Bruno
The Mayor Minister of the Economy of
Finances of industrial sovereignty
and digital
Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
clean up in five days
more than 1,000 businesses have
been ransacked looted for some
set fire to all these acts without exception
are a qualifiable unjustifiable and
inexcusable I was this morning in Arpajon
with the Minister in charge of SMEs
Olivia Grégoire and we first
felt the deep emotion of
merchants but also their confidence
our ability to respond to their
compensation needs like us
have done it all along
crises we have been through since
several years we never
let down the entrepreneurs
traders we won't let them
never fall
we have been negotiating for three days
with insurers specific requests
to which the insurers responded they
will extend the time limit for compensation and
complaints they will allow
to have deductible reductions for
independent traders who have been
most affected and they will bring
simple and quick answers to all
traders
regarding
regarding the condition of Mr.
Deputy I announced this morning that no
only we were ready to postpone to
spread the social and tax charges
but for the most serious cases
Montargis or elsewhere we will cancel
the social security and tax debts of
traders who have been affected but I
would like to say that the first request for
all merchants all over the world
territory which today are worried
are afraid for their business are afraid
for activities it is firmness
it's authority it's security it's
what shampoo the minister of
the Interior and the Minister of Justice
and you understood that the line of
government defended by the first
min Istre is clear recovery
everywhere in the territory of the authority
of State
thank you very much minister
the floor is over to Mrs. Naima mucho for
the horizon group
thank you madam president madam
Prime Minister when the parents
get used to letting their children do their thing
when the children no longer hold
account of their words when the
teachers tremble before their
pupils and prefer to flatter them when
finally young people despise the laws
because they no longer recognize
the authority of nothing or people
above them so then that's where the
beginning of tyranny said Plato in
the Republic Madam the First
minister the violence of the latter
symptomatic days of this France which
not going well
crossed by a crisis of authority and
identity is violence will not be
without short-term consequences
we have to restore order, of course, but
let's be clear there is no point in
repair what has been damaged if it is for
see chaos reoccur these are not
no new billions in the
neighborhoods need and the reason is
simple neither social peace nor
sense of belonging to the nation
can be bought
responsibility for part of the
political class in what is happening
is huge and I want to say it is a
part of the left that questioned
our institutions justifying the use of
force and violence is one
part of the left that fed in
neighborhood youth the feeling
australian hate police
and authority the atmosphere of a
society which would be fundamentally
racist
I told you because I saw it at
the work I heard him come and tell us
this left in my small HLM city of
Val-d'Oise I heard him say the
France rejects you you are not there
your place this part of the left
left no chance for these
populations to hope to form a nation
worse today she thinks to shoot a
political benefit from disorder but she
ends up retreating because she doesn't
masters nothing and in the end it's his
best enemies who try to
take advantage of his best enemies
the extreme right but dear colleagues
a nation thank you save it does not take revenge
no it is urgent that we do
Common Front Madam Prime Minister
you got the big policies
how together can we do
nation
Thanks a lot
the floor is given to Mr. Olivier Véran
government spokesman and Mesnil
recharge democratic renewal
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Gentlemen, ladies and gentlemen, the deputy
Naima mucho you make through your
question a panel of what could
possibly cause the scenes of
violence we witnessed
and by linking this moreover to
political issues I will try to
of your answers by remembering
that it was first the action of the
government since day 1
restore order maintain order 3
never lose sight of these objectives of
keep order for the territories
first victims are traders
are the firefighters are the police
are the police are also the
residents of neighborhoods that have seen
burned public services which saw
decimated stores that have seen
shop windows and entrances and which feel
themselves also victims of the image of
the image that these young people were able to convey
on all the districts it will be necessary
obviously questioning ourselves not for
excuse madam the member it is not the
meaning of your question it will be
interesting in this respect, for example, there
a 4000 people said the guard of the
seals soon 4000 people who have
were arrested many appeared
in court others will
in the next few days it will be
interesting to look at who we have
case when young 12
13-year-olds can meet at the
middle of the night a can of gasoline to
hand to set fire to flag or
a stone in the hand to break a
showcase it was rightly discussed
parental responsibility I believe
not that you have to look for madam
deputy in the cries I believe
not that you have to search today
a ready-made answer and we have
need to learn so that it does not
reproduce more and you are right to
say that the answer will not be in a
surge in public spending in
these neighborhoods but we will need
manage to grasp the ins and outs
outcomes how again
young people of that age were able to come to
that then madam the member of a mode
in a more political way to end my
answer the inhabitants of the districts
concerned to which you make that you
therefore perhaps not mention
political parties as a teacher but they have
memory and they will remember
sooner or later from who was at their side
to restore the organ and services and
waiting for the Instrumentalities
[Music]
the floor is with Madame Nadège love
bangoli for the France group
rebellious Madam President Mr.
the Minister of Justice you have to be
present if we are not related to
said the President of the Republic
arrogant contempt for class and
additional humiliation for
parents from lower-income neighborhoods
the explosion that followed the murder of
Christmas and the symptom of your failure
failure to end the violence
police and beyond with racism the
social relegation then instead
to appease you put the blame on the
others on the weak and you them
humiliate as you humiliated those
and those who have been alerting for
decades you humiliate his parents at
painful job who fight for their
children his parents applauded during the
covid crisis and insult today
additional ignomini the president of the
Medef declares that the first employer
in Seine-Saint-Denis and the traffic of
drug what a lie and what a shame you
humiliate you insult my mother wife of
household she raised 5 Épinay children on
scene in Seine-Saint-Denis you
humiliate Elena d'Aulnay who runs the
flea markets to buy books only at
school we miss humiliating you
parents of the association find the
we at Pavillon-sous-Bois who are struggling
to find speech therapists
psychologists for their children you
humiliating his parents from college Pierre
Curie in Bondy who fight against the
Class closures humiliate you
moms from Aulnay who roam the streets
to calm the legitimate anger of
their children it's mom asks
simply the same social conditions
than others to educate their
children not car education lessons
even today that their
do you promote expeditious justice
for their son who would have nothing and
who damages lives and for his parents
deemed worthy of financial sanctions
for the President of the Republic penal
for you in short the old recipes
from the extreme right this is not the voice
peace and reconciliation
it's madness he has territories
lost of the Republic no there are
territories abandoned by the Republic
it is to this abandonment that we must put a
term with a policy of justice
only minister the parents of the districts
people do their part to
the education of their children when will
you finally assume yours
Thanks a lot
the floor is over to Mr Eric
Dupond-Moretti Minister Keeper of the Seals
of Justice
[Applause]
this speech is absolutely surreal
[Music]
in reality you insulted all the
housekeepers who have brought up well
their children
[Applause]
and don't mind ma'am
deputy in particular mine me I
never hung out on the streets at 11
years you see
and then and then and then naturally
you didn't hear the speech
nuanced that we of course held well
sure that there are parents who do
a lot with little but there are
parents who do nothing with much
and that's what we're aiming for you see
I always said that the mother who
worked at night to raise his
family and maintain it could not
be incriminated but on the other hand the
parents who let their world drag
11 years old 12 years old 13 years old in the streets
when he should be at home at their
home he deserves to be called back to
the hour responsibility you are there
France incendiary incendiary
and by dint of saying that the police
are murderers whom justice does not
worth nothing we can go with impunity
burnt down police stations and courts
you are setting a wonderful example
children you would like to have
the defenders
madam deputy
Mr. Minister, nobody likes
armed missionaries
the floor is over to Monsieur not de Molac
for the group
Thank you Madam Thank you Madam President
My question is for Mr.
minister delegate in charge of housing i
would like to address the issue of areas
strains in terms of housing do not
not a week goes by without me
questioned about the difficulties in
housing during the finance bill
2023 we voted to expand
many municipalities that can be
classified as a tense zone the situation
was critical for example in Brittany
a single tense area the agglomeration of
Nantes
this classification makes it possible to provide the board
council of tools to be able to regulate
the market as the surcharge the
overtaxation forgiveness of residences
secondary the application of a tax on
vacant dwellings or the possibility
rent control for the list
municipalities in tense areas revealed by
the government seems to us too
restrictive only 2600 municipalities are
concerned in France in Brittany
administrative example only 140
municipalities would be concerned, however the
real estate pressure is felt
everywhere else in the Brittany region
asked that the whole region
is placed in a tense zone of more than
the exclusion of certain municipalities such as
Saint-Tropez Vannes or the meeting
asks us minister
do you plan to revise your copy and
relax beyond the 2600 municipalities
initially targeted the scope of
tense area our territories need
concrete tools to fight against
housing crisis trusting
mayors who will be
useful
thank you thank you very much sir
the dep
uté Klein minister in charge of the city and
housing
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
Paul Molac you called him back
zoning and tax change
on vacant premises and tax
residence
secondary is a strong measure of
last finance law of the law of
finance 2023 is the result of a work
of all of you parliamentarians and the
work on the preparation of the list
just ended these 3693 communes
which have been chosen as the result of labor
of quality between the government and the
associations of elected officials for these municipalities
which have been chosen will allow the
mayor because it does fall under a
responsibility of mayors to decide
to apply to apply or not to apply this
tax on vacant premises and this axis
this dwelling axis on errors
secondary it will also allow Homer
greatly increase the possibility
to act on furnished tourist accommodation and
again it is a decision of the
local community and it seems to us
important that it remains a decision of
the local community with my
colleagues Olivia Grégoire and Dominique
Faure you know you care
part we run a committee of
work that will meet on July 18
memory to continue working
on the attrition of housing in the area
tense because yes there is a real one
housing problem everywhere but in
particularly in coastal areas
Brittany in mountain areas so that
the inhabitants of these territories
find accommodation for around sixty
measures are under review
have already been presented to you we will
arbitrate together on the measures that
seem to us the most effective for
continue to work on this measure
but of course so that these measures
are useful at the same time
that everyone takes into account this
need to build everywhere and for
all housing type set for
that the residential course can be
do inside areas
tourist because being an area
tourist it can be a chance we
is often a it's the honor of our
country to be a territory of attraction but
we need to house what dwells
and those who come to work during
the summer periods thank you thank you
yes Minister I believe that we
basically agree it was fair
simply on the number of communes I
think it's important like you
reminded him as I said these are
of the tools that we give to mayors they
can use them or not they have them
several and I believe it is
important indeed that we can
open this set of tools at most
large number today for example
in an area which is however not
very touristy I have people who are
forced to go camping because they
work nearby and that he does not find
no accommodation
here we have to answer that
even the presidency minister
of the Interior on Tuesday, June 27 in the morning
so we discovered with horror the
death of young Naël by the shooting of a
policeman arousing immense emotion
across the country to the president of
the Republic on the same Tuesday evening we
fellow citizens discover with terror the
destruction and rampage organized in
many of our cities angering
of our inhabitants in the face of destruction
unacceptable from their schools from their
town hall of their transport of their service
public of their hospitals of their
police station or their business
in these moments of crisis their is neither
to the analysis nor to the proposals as well
eccentric as they are, the time has come
firmness zero tolerance in the face of these acts
unacceptable that is why I salute
the action of justice I join too
to the strong tribute to our forces of
order and to the firefighters who were put
strained to protect us
tribute with the same force to the elected
as well as to his mothers who relayed
the call for calm tribute also to these
young people who have spoken out
to condemn his acts and to
dissociate the players thus
instrumentalization plans of those who
wanted to use young people from
neighborhoods as a shield to their
political project painfully trying to
hide the betrayal of the left
towards our neighborhoods
shame have on those who have not
stood up for the call for calm shame on those
who take the opportunity to feed
their hatred minister you
you're a neighborhood kid just like
me we call that acting
of a single policeman should not throw the
discredits on all our police
national which protects us and which
honor just as we call to this
that the inexcusable conduct of a
minority of young people from the neighborhoods should not
not discredit the whole
young people from our popular neighborhoods
the relationship between the police and the population
was created the word
[Music]
the floor is given to Mr. Gérald Darmanin
Minister of the Interior and Overseas
thank you madam president madam
Minister Nadia
is that day
in Nanterre during this tragedy which affected
this young driver
the Ministry of the Interior
State authorities lied about what
happened
The answer is no
did that day the policeman who
is the author of this shot was
arrested and taken into custody
answer is yes did that day
after study as the right any citizen
of what happened he was put in
examination, that is to say that there were
serious and concordant clues which
confused and defer to be put
before the destruction of information
open judiciary of the heads of the
charge of open murder issued in
remand the answer is yes
there are not two types of justice
there is no justice for the
powerful for public officials to
the efforts of order and for
other citizens and all those who
peddle the lie undermines the state of
right all those who distort the truth
as you did you elected of the
France insubordinate with abjection and with
no doubt the delight of seeing these
revolt these businesses
burned these schools or the children of
our country on vacation these policemen
it is magistrates these elected officials of whom we put
the address on websites for
call for revenge so yes there is
two types of behavior those that
Republicans who respect your right who
put the rules voted by the
banks speak parliamentarians the
ethics first and those who
choose chaos to grow better
their political forces then you
madam deputy who knew well
its quarters you know that the
police officers often come from these
neighborhoods too and that the inhabitants of
these neighborhoods need the police
so we have to work with all
the nation and distinguish the good from the candy
grain delivered yes we must be strong
against police officers who do not respect
not the law and we have to be very hard
against the offenders who attack them
thank you minister
the floor is to Mrs Émeline kerbidi
for the GDR group
thank you madam president my dear
colleagues, my question is for madam
the Prime Minister and concerns the
police support kitty which has
killed Naël in 5 days this kitty
already reached more than one million euros
much more than its amount it is its
very existence that shocks me and more
again the deafening silence of
government about him
in this moment of crisis that is going through
our country we heard you
called for parental responsibility
demand the greatest justice
firmness multiply the arrests
but when it comes to the kitty you have
timidly announced that she
did not contribute to the appeasement it is little
say here is a kitty created by a
member of the extreme right who organizes
fundraising to help the
murderer of a miner don't you see anything
shocking deeply immoral
manifestly illegal to the existence of
this kitty, however, we remember
of your life reaction about the
kitty that had been created
for Christophe Dettinger this kitty
closed by the site after insistence of the
government madam borne these are your
About you said at the time the
success of this operation is shocking
is it normal to want to bring a
support this gentleman we saw hitting
a policeman on the ground who was seen boxing a
policeman it is also necessary that each
get your bearings today
it's you it's you who lost your
landmarks Madam Prime Minister in
la Fernel a young man lost his life
isn't that less shocking to you
does your inaction have to do with the
connivance of your government with
the extreme right and their will
to instrumentalize this kitty to
lay bare the fractures of our
society if not in the name of morality
Madam Prime Minister take action
less in the name of the right this kitty
cause a disturbance to public order and
the basis of section 1162 of the Code
civil you have the possibility you have
the duty to act what are you waiting for
do it
thank you very much the floor is to Mr.
Gérald Darmanin Minister of the Interior
and overseas
[Applause]
thank you madam the president of the deputy
I expressed myself on this question
a few moments ago the first
minister very clearly also here
48 hours no madam deputy it is not
not in the executive power to be able to
replace judicial decisions and
in the case in the specific case that you
previously mentioned in the same
expression of the government it belongs
as was the case when this
no one had attacked a policeman
court to make the decision
to apply the Civil Code and to
close this kitty madam deputy
however, I would like to say here and without
say anything to each other since none
member of the government created this
pot all the same the deputy that if we
could respect two principles
first principle of balance and
weighting the country isn't it already
quite eruptive and our fellow citizens
is he not responsible for all
policies not to use each
pretext for politics
politician
secondly including this policeman who
been indicted who was warned
on sight and who was in tension
temporary this policeman like all the
people who have not been convicted by
justice definitely has the right to
the presumption of innocence if we
respect these two balances
remember that it is not the minister
of the Interior which applies justice
but the justice that applies the codes
civilians that you vote here I believe that
the Republic will then be well guarded
thank you very much minister
madam carbidi i see that there is
obviously two weights of measurement because
than in the previous case madam
borde and Madame Chiappa had not
absolutely not embarrassed to say that this
kitty was a shame and that's fine
because they had intervened
the kitty had been suspended and the
justice thank you madam deputy
the floor is given to Mrs Justine Bruet
for the Republicans group
thank you madam president madam
Prime Minister for several days
France offers to the eyes of the world a
very sad face pictures of
unacceptable urban violence by
ménils pastors teenagers in the Jura
until the cowardly assassination attempt
of the mayor of L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent Jean
Brun I wish to associate myself with the many
testimonials of support for him
wife and her children
its daily commitment such as that
of all our seas and remarkable and must
to be greeted just as they should be
also the immense courage of our
firefighters of our gendarmes of our
national and municipal police who
are the guardians of peace and
the republican order to be elected is
take responsibility when
order is threatened in our country these
punish firmly and quickly
when a violent minority destroys
saying it all is fine not all have
this clarity in the hemicycle but to act
it's better law enforcement is
faced with increasing rioters
youngest between 14 and 18 years old and
more and more determined it's a terrible
admission of failure in education and
parental responsibility
to which we do not want to resolve ourselves
Madam Prime Minister
we expect strong actions from you
to establish authority in our country
and fight against the failure of
some parents
the time is no longer for empty words and
half measures in education
urgent action is needed to
reaffirm the values ​​of our
Republic it goes through a school
strong a school that values ​​the taste of
effort and respect for the body
teacher but a school that does not
does not replace parents who have
rights and duties our family
politician had passed a law in
2010 which withdrew part of the allowances
in case of absenteeism at school repeal
in January 2013 while the left
was in power so my question is
simple are you now able to
resume this measure and sanction
parents who quit
the education of their children I
thanks
the floor is with Mr.
Eric Dupont-Moretti keeps the seals
Justice Ministry
madam deputy
I believe that
the reasons that led
quite violent absolutely not
qualifiable unbearable denounced by
almost everyone here
these are obviously reasons
multiple
multifactorial
these things are very difficult and we
find I was going to say cleavages
traditional between those who say nothing
has been done in terms of the policy of
the city and others who say
things have been done and then those who
say this is what we did
matter of education can pose a
a number of questions of respect
of our institutions police justice
obviously and things naturally
are not simple I have besides
asked the prosecutor to make me
trace their precise analysis to no
only the age but the motivations of the
young people who have been found
commit abuses why there is
a simplistic discourse which consists in
say it's determinism what we have
heard earlier do you see and this
that we will hear again who is a
disempowerment speech
absolutely unbearable and then
I I think I just think
that that we put forward that the
determinism bleeding our freedom is
no more complicated than that because
as I said a moment ago
has housekeepers who bring up well
their children and there are children who
do not commit offenses
all of this all of this all of this all of this
is a matter of nuance and I
would like to say again instead who is the
mine than Gérald Darmanin and I
assume the answer we have
brought in man in staff and we
let us all of course pay homage here to the
police to gendarmes to firefighters to
magistrate to the clerk who were at the
meet our obligations then
madam madam
thank you very much minister
[Music]
the floor is with Mrs. Blandine Broca
for the Democrat group
thank you madam president madam
minister arises from SMEs and trade
in 2022 multi-risk loss insurance
operating revenue increased by 10% in 2023
8% how much for next year
even though only one trade in on
two take out loss insurance
operating not to mention the
deductibles to be paid
immediately the employees you need
pay at the end of the month for amenities
that it was necessary that it will still be necessary to pay
in an attempt to further secure
it showcases its business in front of this
deep disarray the state must respond
present also minister how
can we predict the acceleration of
building permit procedures
for the shops destroyed indeed
beyond the financial support the speed
responses is essential
and he evidently goes the same from the side
insurers Madam Minister for
all those whose tool
work was ransacked leaving them a
feeling of life and work destroyed
can you tell us the measurements
you will take to support our
merchants and above all for their
allow to work
that's all he asks of you
thank you thank you very much madam
deputy the floor is to Mrs. Olivia
Grégoire Deputy Minister in charge of SMEs
trade in handicrafts and
Tourism thank you Madam President
[Applause]
thank you for your words madam
taunts towards traders and
especially independent traders
which numbering about a thousand
have been affected during these few
days of the packs thank you too
to have repeated their words I had
the opportunity to be by their side this morning at
Arpajon but also yesterday Paris 15th
before even talking about compensation
even before speaking tomorrow
I think it's very important too
to take the measure of their step
psychological and I want to tell you
that
in each prefecture of France the
crisis recovery advisors
are of course mobilized to support
load spreads see
cancellation of tax debts and
social security of traders who will have been
the most affected but I also want to say
that the departmental advisers to the
exit from the crisis can accompany
morally traders who are the
more flabbergasted because I believe that the
word that works is the word of
amazement about tomorrow
we have already brought together several
times with Bruno Le Maire at the
request from the Prime Minister
insurers but also bankers
asked them two things
be fast be it simple so that
it's faster we will also leave
time to amazement to pass it
it takes days for the amazements
lose so pass traders
will not have 5 days but 30 days already
to return to their insurer and
we will have in the weeks that
come the President of the Republic
has just announced a law that will
raise the issue of deadlines for the
reconstruction both on the pane
municipalities of course which have been
affected but also to support the
merchants and to make it happen
as soon as possible when in doubt
reflexes to have very simple
first file a complaint second
call his insurer I take the liberty of
recall its evidence in the hubbub
but the evidence is major I tell you
thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
for the group la France insoumise
Madam Prime Minister the death of the
young Christmas killed by a policeman shows to
what point should be changed
police doctrine it was one of the
plan proposals presented by
Jean-Louis Borloo in 2018 among others
on transportation early childhood the
culture sport employment the means
for municipalities the fight against
discriminations this plan came from
the call of Grigny which brought together more than
1000 people responsible
associations of local elected representatives of the seas who
were working on a report named
made Eco today live big
living together the Republic for a
national reconciliation 19 major
measures that we could discuss but which
allowed to give a new
ambition for our neighborhoods that it be
located in large or small
cities when we did Monsieur Macron
he threw it in the trash with my prizes
arrogance everyone here gets away with it
remembers
from what vision for the neighborhoods
priorities of the city none in these
neighborhoods as elsewhere you have
degraded public services by your
health policies
education justice housing
becomes associative force a nation
it's cohesion what cohesion
propose yourself as the so aptly says
mayor of Trappes Ali discount about
those who refuse to build
social housing in their municipality, which
thinks he can stay between the rich and who
think that their individual happiness
will never be struck by misfortune
collective organized in our suburbs
are heavily deceiving sooner or later they will be
late catch up like everyone is
Today
poor people's ghettos only exist
because there are rich geckos there
must end with the separatism of these
latter and he also enforces the
republic law
what will be your measures for
ensure this cohesion to recover
common law and public services of
quality everywhere, a fortiori in our
neighborhoods let us remember that the inhabitants of
these are part of the essentials
which relate more to society which does not
perceives our country does not turn the
I call Mr Olivier Klein
Minister delegate in charge of the city and
housing
[Applause]
thank you, Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
pickman first let me turn
to obviously have a thought for
Christmas a thought for this firefighter
a thought for all the forces of
security who have worked
relentlessly over the last few days
a thought for the elect a thought too
for all officials and
residents of these neighborhoods
then popular in terms of
Borloo plan or the Deep plan Bordeaux if
you looked at him with attention as
we did we you will see that
it's part of the inspiration of
the action of the five-year government
previous I want to recall the cities
educational including the President of the
République announced in Marseille as soon as
Monday evening its extension to the whole
cities in city policy
important axis of the Borlo plan and
moreover you said that it does not
was useless a few days ago
in the press it's the street during the
quinquennium preceding us when we
took over the leadership of this country
had 5 billion for the street 12 years ago
billion and the state returned to
street funding while he had
disappeared when
it is today more than 1500 building sites
everywhere in France among the 453
territories in neighborhoods in streets past
in agreement 445 are already under construction
this construction site works and this construction site is
extremely important the Borloo plan
it's less children in the in
school is therefore
separation of CP to 12 CE1
extension in large sections and
the President of the Republic has
announced in Marseille is the reception of
two-year-old children in the next
income and increased resources
for the middle sections the Borlo plan
it's more culture in the neighborhoods
popular are the microfolies that the
government continued to support
throughout the previous five-year period and
to develop its 150 microfolies in
popular neighborhoods are
extremely important for children
of these neighborhoods the Borlo plan is
more culture is the opening of
libraries and again the
previous government supported
the opening of libraries to
staggered hours in particular the
Sunday the Port Blanc was put in
work and thank you thank you
the floor is with Mr. Denis masseglia
for the Renaissance group
Thank you, Madam President, Mr.
Minister
misunderstanding strikes us all
for a week
misunderstanding first of all in the face of
terrible tragedy that happened to
Nanterre and which cost the life of the young
Naël to his loved ones I repeat our
trust in justice to do all
light on this drama
the misunderstanding then vis-à-vis the
troubles you have been witnessing since
several nights and in the face of which our
law enforcement are more than
never engaged i want them in
thank
a blind anger seems to have taken hold
of the whole territory not only in
the big cities but also in the one
less dancing usually calmer i
want as proof the city of Cholet 56
000 inhabitants confronted for the
first time to such violence I
understand the anger when it denounces
the discreet everyday but I refuse
to understand gratuitous violence
what tries here to justify I refuse
to understand that associations
find the tires of their vehicle
punctured that traders discover
their store looted and that the elect
be attacked as far as their home Cholet
it is neither a very dense urban area
nor rurality
Cholet is a medium-sized town where it
life is good or the unemployment rate is
by 4.6%
where companies are just waiting to
hiring Cholet is an average city
as there are so many in France and in
the inhabitants do not understand that a
minority ransack burns attack
on this territory there is no lack
yet no subjects for which
mobilize with conviction but in the
respect I am thinking for example of the lack
from doctor to lack of law enforcement
this is where our focus should be
energy of elected officials and support for
public authorities Minister
what to answer to the million French people who
live in these territories confronted
everyday with difficulties
structural and to this feeling of
abandonment
thank you for the cohesion of the territories
Madam President, ladies and
Honorable Members, Mr. Deputy
massiglia
there are 553 municipalities at the moment when we
who we talk about since
the middle of last week
experienced damage of a few
it wouldbe
who made the headlines because
that there are events of a seriousness
particular that took place
there are the big cities the neighborhoods
city ​​policies and then there are
a new geography which we do not have
usual in these 553 municipalities there are
has 170 who don't have a quarter
city ​​policy and in which the
explanations and shortcuts
would explain what we lived in
the others we have 120 in
which the inhabitants who live in
political districts of the city are
less than 3,000 in municipalities including
we speak
and that the time of the analysis the will
of the President of the Republic to make
to take the time to look
things to watch also what are
the profiles of these 4000 issuers who have
been challenged beyond their average
of age beyond their youth what is it
that it is characterized what makes us
lets measure what we missed
if we are wrong about the diagnosis we
will have difficulty bringing the right
answers and to be very concrete
Cholet is a good example of a town
which is in the top 100 municipalities where
it is good to live in a municipality in
which indeed there is no
difficulties of this type that we had been able to
spot during the 2005 riots or
since is it as they say
the propagation also by the networks
social which means that at one point we
felt communities of destinies is it
that it is linked to hatred against
institutions is it the
pretext which then allows to commit
acts of predation which is
certain Mr. Deputy is that
behind your question there is the great
interrogation which should go beyond the
right truly question us
take a few minutes
so that everyone comes out of the box the
report which he thinks is the
solution the proposal he had
made during the last presidential
but on the contrary look at the eyes in
the eyes what we need
today thank you Minister
the floor is given to Mrs. Marine Le Pen
president of the unity group
national
thank you madam president my question
addressed to the Prime Minister
at a time when our country has just been
handed over to looting, pillage and a
senseless incendiary rage I would like
ask you the question everyone asks
the French what have you done with the
France you who lead the same policy
than you predecessors for 40 years
what have you done with our country
staking out areas of a location that
you let this communalize this
criminalize what did you do when
you have allowed ignorance to prosper
of our culture the hostility towards
of the legal authority of the state
the illegitimacy of our laws and the hatred
of our people what have you done for
transform our country among the most
most elegant and most courteous
sweet from the earth to make it a hell
or it consumes with public buildings
which however burn in the future
this spectacle afflicts the whole world and
our country which was so much admired for its
intellectual influence and its power
arouses pity today when this
ain't the irony you never fired
no lesson from the 2005 riots no
more of the Stade de France which leaves
augur a security disaster for the Olympics
of 2024 and with it a new
national humiliation the truth is
that you didn't want to hear
warning what happens to us
predicted it despite a large
adversity I say it with sadness and
gravity we had unfortunately
right when you're about to
give us another billion to
umpteenth lead suburb I'm calling you at
courage from self-criticism to humility
to admit the dramatic failure of your
policies, we must first and foremost
stop lawless immigration or you
are making the problem worse
communitarianism or even separatism and
to disseminate it in the smallest village
then you have to take control
all the districts of France restore
parental authority redo
the school the crucible of the Republic
bring justice firmly without
which she will remain powerless to
protect the French thank you
economic and judicial security thank you
possible the national
the floor is to Mrs. Elisabeth Borne
Prime Minister
madam the first minute ladies and
gentlemen deputies madam
President Le Pen so yes Madam
President, I listened with great
intentions of your intervention and I have
believed for a moment that there could be
proposals but until the end until the
bout you once again demonstrate the
only thing you are capable of is
the caricature and you see madam the
President I regret even if it does not
come as no surprise that the choice
you do it's that of the division
and when I hear the president of your
opposite side the rural territories and
neighborhoods as if helping one
had to rob the others I tell myself
you definitely haven't changed and
when I hear again at the moment
pointed out some parts of our
population I say to myself again the
caricatures really you will not escape it
no I think today while
our country while many mayors
live in difficult situations then
that traders and craftsmen have done
in the face of a lot of violence not
to play the unity of the country is it is not
Responsible Madam President Le Pen
it's not responsible
so see for our part we will be
always in support of our police officers
our gendarmes our firefighters
municipal police officers local elected officials
and we will all always be mobilized
to fight against violence but we
are also mobilized to fight
against the poison of division and when
our Republic is under attack it is
national unity which must prevail i
thank you thank you very much madam
Prime Minister
government question time is
finished the meeting is suspended
the meeting is resumed the agenda
calls the continuation of the discussion of
orientation bill and a
Department of Justice programming
2023 2027 last night the assembly
continued the examination of the articles
stopping amendment number 328 at
section 3 before moving on to this
amendment a point of order tool
of which article
thank you Madam President for
article 133 of our regulations
interior
we had known the admissibility
financial with variable geometry us
have known
the study of amendments to geometry
variable and so we just
know the two minutes of time of
speak during question and answer sessions
variable geometry government
that is to say that the president of
the Assembly has systematically left
outflank the deputies of the groups
macronists the ministers Auban the
president of the Rassemblement group
national but it is allowed suddenly
cut on the other hand to two minutes exactly
microphone of several deputies, in particular of
my group it is not possible in fact
let this time be free
appreciation of the president of
the National Assembly either we give more
2 minutes to everyone either in
in exactly two minutes to the deputy
but the rules must be the
same and apply in the same way
for everyone the rules are
same and applies in the same way
for everyone the president of
the National Assembly oversees the
regulation and in particular and in particular
section 133 so thank you and
the rules are applied in a manner
impartial in this hemicycle then
amendment first in joint discussion
not in common discussion
identical amendments on 328 madam
mayan height
thank you Madam President I wanted
take advantage of the defense of this amendment
to nevertheless ask the
minister because we are more
more embarrassed in the hemicycle to speak
of the bill even though we
have thousands of clerks who have
been on strike yesterday and who are waiting to
us and who expect from us
pieces of information that we do not
can't give them I think
we could in a time that you
would suit minister
remember what you want to do
talk about this remuneration of course
substantial number of magistrates alongside
of which that revalued from
clerks really don't cut the figure
not the figure and we need
cohesion at a time when we have
really need that
courts work well you got it
recalled during the questions to the
Government it seems necessary to us
human simply human to do in
so that we can talk about the
situation of clerks and see how
we can evolve on this subject here
Minister, thank you for
your attention on this matter don't see
polemical but wish
transparency finally on the amendment
himself I am taking up an amendment from
Senate which limits teleconsultation
during the extension of custody
view to people who have already done
the subject of a face-to-face examination is
a provision which was deleted in
law commission we wish the
restore the conditioning of the
recourse to teleconsultation in the event of
extension of police custody
seems to be a good choice providing the
necessary medical guarantees which
beyond the clinical examination have a
look at the adaptation of the place to the state
health of the person concerned
it is not the lack of the number of
practicing physicians who must do the
right and I think we have to and
moreover when the gathering
national express themselves yesterday I want to their
say that if they were very concerned about
medical desertification in the middle
rural and well he could support the
device we wanted
set up and on which we
work in a transpartisan manner
For years
thank you always identical amendment the
503 Mr Brico
yes thank you Madam President
which has just been defended by our
colleague and which aims to restore
the framework provided by the two
rapporteurs of the present in the Senate
with regard to the use of
teleconsultation during the extension
custody thank you
thank you and always the same time
1319 Mr Yordanov thank you Madam
prison yes indeed this amendment
reinstated the Senate drafting
and it seems to us indeed that it is not
Not possible
to have a medical teleconsultation
in custody for the for the therefore
the extension of police custody
renewal without whom beforehand
less a physical visit and therefore it
I think it's an amendment when
even very reasonable it was the
Senate editorial thank you
the committee Mr Rapporteur
it's an unfavorable opinion we got the
debate in committee I think I will
not repeat the arguments I repeat
simply that we have a certain number of
framework for this possibility of
medical visit and especially the
possibility of refusal by the interested party
or the family therefore unfavorable opinion
Mr. Minister of
governs the president madam the deputy
Mayer height
on the substance of the amendment I am
obviously in the same position as the
rapporteur you ask questions about
the clerks naturally it is a
duty for me than to answer you
first the clerks were increased
by 12%
since I became a Keeper of the Seals
and we are working on a grid
this grid
is not finalized and I had indicated to the
clerk there are many times
moreover, the dedicated calendar
would be the fall
I understand and I hear their legitimacy
naturally impatient
I saw the protest movement
and not only do I hear but he
obliges me of course but we don't have
finished our job it's a job
multiple protean first pluri
interministerial ministerial but
also work with the different
organizations
unions and I think as I have
already announced that this fall
we can suggest things that
will obviously be finalized that it is
a little early for the moment here madam
member what can I tell you about
this question but the clerks
to whom I am very attached and who
make justice work on a daily basis
of our country will not be forgotten
and your opinion on the three amendments
identical I said madam
President that I was on the same
position that
Mr. Minister then Mr.
Shrek
thank you Madam presence yes for
respond to our colleague indeed
we are aware of the deserts
medical because mostly and
frequently we are chosen
actually in constituencies
rural and indeed we see
the state of abandonment of public services and
in particular of the hospital state of abandonment
also we notice it for the
justice and I must say that the group
socialist when you were in power
I don't know at the hospital but in any case
justice than the quinquennium of
Mr Hollande was marked by a
abandonment and a budgetary ordeal and
human of justice so i think that
before criticizing your colleagues
look what you generated i
come to the amendment where you wished
offer the exam by video only
when there has been a face-to-face examination
can understand it but in truth your
amendment had the idea
because imagine that at the beginning of the
custody of the defendant and refused
this review as it often happens and
fine if you don't have a doctor when
of renewal it does with your
amendment he will not see any doctor or
at the start or at the recovery in 48 hours
here is the consequence of your amendment
accordingly that one and the Germans
identical we will vote against thank you
Madame rebois
so I am against these amendments
which go against the interests of the
guardian for life since it is precisely
when it is difficult to make a
physical examination that is used
telemedicine or medicine tv did
its evidence and this measure goes in
interest of health and integrity
physical appearance of the person in custody and
it would be a shame to deprive yourself of this
tool to use which is good
framed this was recalled by the
protractor
Sir
Mrs
because I got
no problem thank you madam president
we have an interesting debate
because why do we resort
finally could we have recourse to
this
teleconsultation because there are
medical deserts because the service
public of the hospital was completely
destroyed decades ago
policy
ultra liberal so what we see is
that in addition to killing them destroying our
public services by these policies we
come to cut corners on the rights
fundamental because this place
fundamental to be able to have a real
face-to-face doctor and so on
this word but let's say for a consultation
medical is the minimum it is the
at least I'll tell you again
it is the Council of State that considers
that this measure aims to overcome the
difficulties resulting from the lack of
doctor in certain territories and
the saturation of the health system in
others therefore to try to compensate
politics
neoliberalism that has been raging for years
and you continue
the government that the government
current continues to lead to pursue
we come to trim rights
fundamentals Mr rapporteur
when you tell us that you don't want
not satisfy this amendment because
it is written that the principal concerned
keep him in sight could refuse but
they still need to know and
people who are who find themselves in
police custody often do not know
their rights
that's also the problem
the deputy I will put to the king it is
amendment 328 and identical which have
also an unfavorable opinion of the
commission and the government which is
For
who is against they are not adopted
amendments submitted for discussion
commune from 580 to Madame Ménard
yes thank you Madam President
it is an amendment which seeks to
write black on white that
when using telemedicine
requires the express consent of the person
who is kept in custody so I confess to you
that it is an appeal amendment because
that I find that the drafting of the
Linea 7 to me does not seem extremely
clear but I know the LACORE express
of the person requesting the examination and
asking yes but who is requesting the examination
but if it is not he who requests
the exam are they asked for their
ok, that's actually the question
it's just a call amendment for
have an answer to this question and
then and then I just wanted maybe
respond to my colleague from France
rebellious who explains that keeping them at
don't know their rights
seems that the baba is that precisely
the place their sound systematically
recalled when they are in custody so
for that I am not too worried
but I have a concern about Korea
express of the one who asks when this
is not he who asks for the exam I
thank you thank you the 504 I am
not sure
mister holy oil you are not
signatory
seems like his signature
so no you are not a signatory
Mr rapporteur opinion of the
commission on the 580
maybe it will help to move forward a bit
faster then that's the plan
the text because what you ask
Mrs Mrs Mrs Ménard if the person
asks for a medical examination his family or
himself will absolutely be able to oppose
video conferencing require review
physical medical this is exactly what
is written I add and it is important
that the doctor can also oppose it
and prefer a medical examination then there
in case the person does not have it
asked good already if the person does not
not ask for a medical examination if there is
a proposed medical examination
by the prosecutor and that the prosecutor
request a medical examination it is already a
advanced in relation to the fact that there is
no medical examinations and in this case
indeed since it has no solid
since he did not ask for a review
medical there is no reason for it
who can oppose it
explicitly as desired
therefore unfavorable opinion thank you Mr.
keep that government coat
unfavorable I will put Madame Ménard
if even the president forgive me but
it's not at all logical if it's the
prosecutor who offers him the examination
medical precisely the question that I
I was asking is it planned the
correction of the guard on sight
Well that's a problem I think.
and it would be nice if it was
indeed since it is the prosecutor
who offers the medical examination
keep it seen can we can
ask for the express consent of the person
whether the medical examination is on video is in
video medicine in telemedicine forgiveness
that's the question and if it's not the
case I would like it to be
actually explicitly listed
thank you sir reporter
keep it in sight
do not ask for the medical examination we are
ok prosecutor
wish there was a medical examination
well maybe there are good reasons
for which the prosecutor wishes
medical examination so if the person does not
not going to the best not that she can do it
oppose since there may be
real reasons and in these cases if the
doctor can always tell him wait
I prefer to see the person so there is
no there really is no topic on these
questions and in the hearings we
have done on these issues we are
did say it was rather really
a step forward to keep them in sight
thank you Madame Ménard is rolling now yes
then it is maintained he received a notice
unfavorable to the commission and the
government that is for
who is against it is not adopted the
sir i think he is not
defended identical amendments on
168 Mrs. Martin Mr. Pouget oh yes
thank you Madam President then to
contrario, this amendment aims to lighten
simplify the procedure for appealing to the
teleconsultation to carry out the examination
medical in the case of the extension of
police custody by lifting the need to
obtain the consent of the respondent to
time when it takes three hours
rules for finding a doctor
and that it is complicated at best in question
or his family and as we said
since yesterday there is always the faculty
of the doctor to stop the teleconsultation
and ask for a clinical examination thank you
an amendment
identical Mister Shrek the 418 defended
Mr. Guignot on 659
defended Mr. Laura Mr.
draftsman of the committee's opinion
unfavorable we had the debate before
commission thank you sir the guard
thank you I will put yes madam
thank you Madam President I think
it would be good if we had two
things in mind the first is that
this case of medical consultation
through new technologies but
generally not considered a
progress but rather globally
considered as a piset including for
those in everyday life who
moreover practical it has just been said
that keep them in sight if they don't
did not know their rights
saw them explanations that
allowed to know them I think
that at least a minimum have the
possibility of refusing this type of examination
which is not really a medical examination
is not acceptable including on the
plan of the rights of which the people who
are in custody including
possibly prolong retains its
rights
thank you i will put in the way
identical amendments which received a
unfavorable opinion of the commission and the
government that is for
who is against are not adopted
mr closet the 280
Madam President Mr.
Minister, Mr. Rapporteur, my
dear colleagues, this is
essentially to specify the space
temporal in which it is visit
medical to be carried out and although
technical developments
allow today to realize
this remote examination by video
transmission the article finally the paragraph
that I propose is to confirm
to express the fact that this
the temporal space in which this examination
can be carried out either in the same
provided that the how to say that
physical examination i.e. within a time
three hours from the request
thank you thank you sir
draftsman of the committee's opinion is
a good concern but it is
satisfied it is article 63-3 of the code
penal which its refers therefore it is
satisfied fully satisfied thank you
Mr. Keeper of the Seals
and same position
identical amendments on 524
sir Vincent d yes thank you madam
President Mr. Rapporteur
minister in committee we
had a debate on TV
consultation and in particular on
reasons that could allow
the exclusion of this passage to the
telemedicine and we had agreed
moreover a subscription of the rapporteur
had been adopted in committee
we agreed that it was better
enshrine in law rather than send back
a decree in Council of State is these
exclusions and this amendment comes
just make it very clear
more
precise if you allow yourself
the expression of the reasons which will allow
exactly
how to say to better frame this
procedure and this will allow after the
rewriting and adoption of this
amendment to have a security
legal on the procedures a lot
more important thank you
the gentleman reporter 829
thank you Mr. Vincent des and Mr.
placard for for this common amendment
which comes from the work we had
started leading in auditions and
in committee we had wanted the
enter a number of exclusions
in in
the hardness of the text and not leave it to
a decree is what we did in the
work that has been done we even added
an element that had not been added
initially deafness since he gave us
been reminded that it was an element
important to add so we have here a
precise device that frames and gives
additional guarantees on
this this new possibility by
example and it will not allow me to not
to be obliged to restore life for all
the amendments that we are going to have
the hour on the age on the on the handicap
etc. it is totally satisfied by the
seventhly therefore when the person
has an apparent health problem
or particular vulnerabilities
vulnerability so all these amendments
I will give you an unfavorable opinion
soon it won't be worth it
that we have the debate so we resumed our
discussions we took over the amendment
initial that I had done rewritten for
make it more readable and more
still understandable and we added the
deafness therefore obviously favorable opinion
thank you sir the keeper of the seals
same opinion Madam President in favor
thank you madam mart
in it is true that it is good to quote a
a number of situations where the
use of telemedicine and absolutely
impossible
First of all, I wonder about
this particular situation which is
made for those in custody
for violence or contempt committed against
person with authority
public or for rebellion I do not see
not very good why good he would he
would be concerned but what attracts
more my attention is the
seventh point when the person
has an apparent health problem
or of particular vulnerability I
understand the reasons for
which this case was written
in this way but who will determine
the apparent health problem
It's still very, very vague.
who will determine the fact that this
person is a health problem
apparent
thank you yes sir reporter
good already you see when I say it again
because when we work on
amendments and that we manage to find
agreements we get to work
together and I thank Mr Vincent
on this question I invite you
sometimes to do the same thing on the side of
the extreme left of the hemicycle
this question is important but
precisely she is satisfied finally I
understand your concern but if the
prosecutor if he sees that the person I
don't know i'm going to be caricatural
bleeds good we will not ask obviously
an opinion but forgiveness it will be
medically physical if the prosecutor
did not see for example something and
that the doctor starts the
teleconsultation and who sees that the
nobody all strongly he says to himself hey
I'm a doctor I know it's
maybe a very big bronchitis and
not just something he can
stop the teleconsultation and go to
a physical consultation if necessary
so this aspect and I and it is satisfied
and I think we bring there really
strong guarantees on this device
thank you, Mr rapporteur, I will
vote on these amendments
identical including a moment of the protractor
who receives the favorable life of the
commission and favorable from the government
who is for
who is against they are adopted and they
drop all the amendments
until
1212 included
so we go to 919 sir then
I don't know who is defending him, Madame Martin
Sir
he is defended
defended Mr. rapporteur
unfavorable Minister
I'll put it to the woods with a notice
unfavorable to the commission and the
government that is for
who is against is not adopted
amendment 1442 gentleman housekeeper
mr shrek mr housekeeper
the proper administration of justice
requires the existence of a procedure
effective guaranteeing both the
requirements of the trial that hits for all
parts and characterization of
possible breaches in this regard
unfolding of all the steps
preceding the holding of a potential
trial must not exceed a time limit
excessive which would harm the quality of the good
processing of the file, which is why the
this amendment is intended to
reduce the maximum duration applicable
to the preliminary inquiries which
appears as a procedural means of
guarantee the collection period of
necessary items without wearing
breach of reasonable delusion indeed
it's intolerable to have citizens
which for two years are under investigation
preliminaries without having access to this
that he would have precisely reproached without
have access to the parts it is proposed
therefore to reduce from two years to one year for
the common rights of course not
for organized crime not for
terrorism thank you
another debate we had in committee
well it goes completely against de
text economy what you what
you write more I am a little
surprised to see you shorten the
delays than police officers
find forgiveness in judicial policeman
actually finds it too short to lead
well their investigation so you want
put and its method from you
impediments to our officers
of the judicial police so it is
obviously precisely so as not to risk
the cancellation of the police investigations that
we propose to adjust the deadlines for
that the preliminary investigation since the law
trust or deadlines had been
strongly shortened we see that so many
that the means are not yet
arrived in the jurisdictions we cannot
not hold them so that's something
which is rather
logical and good policy to say
it doesn't work we just have and we have we have
just again again when we have
even more means in the
jurisdictions
minister opinion of the
government
on the objectives, sir, we
East
Totally agree
there was no time limit before but
then not at all under
the empire of the Code of Criminal Instruction
the investigation was called the investigation
unofficial that is to say
so sometimes we investigated three years
four years with a little soap opera
media and yes everyone sees
what can I allude to and in
reality the suspect never knew
really what he was accused of but
selected pieces of his guilt
I but this Guimet watch is
regularly published when I
wished it would end very clearly
and in the text that I carried who has
been voted confident text we limited the
duration of the preliminary investigations
turns out that
we are unable at the moment to
meet deadlines so you have to be
pragmatic you have to look at things
lucidly this is the reason why
contrary to what you suggest
we are proposing to lengthen a bit but
by allowing access to
contradictory because it is not
normal at all at all at all to be
suspected for so long without
never really know what you are
reproach and without you having the
opportunity to exercise your rights
in particular with a lawyer who will have
complete knowledge of the file therefore
this is the meaning of this how would i say
of this adjustment and I will tell you
things
we want more police
you know the Minister of the Interior
carried a text that was voted i
wish for me
obviously more magistrates is
the text that I have the honor to present
in front of you when all this will be put in
instead we can come back to these deadlines me
I'm not giving up if I dare say
because as soon as we have
Thank you, Madam President, Mr.
rapporteur minister
the amendment of my household colleague in
practically the nature of a
appeal amendment since we are
all agree to say one hour that
a preliminary investigation which lasts one
contestably in the presumption
of innocence since we have a soap opera
certain aspects of the files and an update
in question can not react and if I
reflect on the principle
of equality for men and that will be the
civil party if there is no response
after a plant within six months at the
opportunity to serve as a magistrate
instructor there is a complaint with a
civil party prostitution so we
see that there is a problem and the
question of the deadline in reality and
maybe the government can
to ask would mean that at the end
one year if the preliminary investigation has not
did not succeed that training
automatically opening a
judicial information at the request of the
wooden floor and I think we can find
an intelligent economy on this subject
having the right of them is complicated
but it's complicated because also we
talks about a survey of investables with
international investigations by
example you have understood that it is
not possible so we tried to
to adjust because he thinks we are not
not come and that it is a text that
I am convinced it will not
final and for good reason because it is
a serious violation
of human rights than to let
like that art like that
a survey of the winter vitamin without
have but I will still reassure
national representation the principle
is an active principle it did not let me
before text trust because you
know the people who have been the people who
were targeted like that for three
four years which was to
which became bearable in reality
so already having a small principle is
to know how to put one foot in the neck of
the door and we'll come back to it as soon as
we will have noted better from the earth wall
as a magistrate also as a prosecutor
vote the text
here to say that the main brake in
preliminary investigations on TVs
it's the lack of police investigators
judiciary and judicial colleagues
who is example and in great difficulty
and who claims to be considered as his
just up and not as she goes
the being of the departmentalized in the face of we have
seen in the last few days or how much she
was turned immediately from these
missions but that there were
problems in the public here
maybe a clue how
speed up the investigations nevertheless we have
makes an offer the 919 subscription
that was swept away from a father's hand
and who nevertheless was of a birth
young transparte herbal tea since she
was thoughtful she was colleagues
Didier Paris as part of the
Commission in which on
independence from the obstacle
the independence of justice which was
to say maybe let's not put a
delegate after but a delay from
of which we had proposed there a year all
the years the JLD must finally the prosecutor
must go see the JLD to say bah
listen i still need time to
clearly investigate a control in
as such on proportionality
actually part of the investigation
preliminary to the objectives pursued
here and we justify we watch try
an international investigation because he
there needs to be compliments it is
justified the controlled gildr and we
continues to score the preliminary and
without it cutting because
that if not and finally France neither by
to say yes but in which field he
would rather have such a delay yes there is
such a scenario where there all the same there
has no international dimension and
Suddenly it would still be abused than that
lasts 3 years because the text allows it
it had to last well we get out of it
not like do a regular review by
the detention liberties judge
here is the proposal that seemed to me
be the most reasonable and above all
of her operational so as not to
lose in time such as the fairy
the Keeper of the Seals and I have for once
for me the anteriority of the proposal
since we discussed it at the time
where deadlines had come on the table
obviously therefore the delays of the investigations
too long foreplay
concludes concern many people there
included in this policy
it's been a while since we
let's raise this issue with the Minister
of Justice and that we have decided
to shorten the time so be
simply eliminatory, you should know that
these preliminary investigations for in
their too short duration because of real
problems currently at the prosecutor
who are worried about having to place
business because they can't
complete the preliminary investigation
pass the deadline so we have to
responsibility take into account these
constraints of these constraints in
effective in the judiciary and have
also this look at the opening of
contradictory almost a certain delay
it seems fair to us
thank you i will put here mom 1742
on the favorable video of the commission
and of the government which is for and
against it is not adopted the 737
thank you madam president sir
Minister Mr Rapporteur and it is
an editorial moment aims to insert the
coordinating conjunction next to
the text in order to ensure the guarantees
procedures and principles count
in the course of investigations
legal proceedings thus preserving the rights
fundamentals of the people concerned i
thank you thank you sir
protractor
I thank Madam for being vigilant on
this little one
shell which remained sheltered from the
reporter's gaze
[Music]
coordinating conjunctions are fine
useful that you have been vigilant I
am in favor of your amendment thank you
i will put 137 coins
adopt identical amendments 26 i
got dented
er
it's not the same coordination I I
feel that there is a perfume
particular
with this amendment 26 the idea and
to be able to allow
to citizens who are implicated by
example in the context of an investigation
preliminary to have access to the back
folder of the entire course excurser
items that could be
tricky secret not to bring the
particular difficulty but today
there is no access to the folder and it is
true that the one who is paused her
does not know the elements that have
of accusation which already deprives him
first of all true information and
and surround him with adults and then don't
does not necessarily allow to
defend as it should and we do not
finally has no respect for
contradictory so here is the idea of
this amendment and the proposal that
resulting
thank you I will add a little good to be
says that this is an amendment therefore aims to
strengthen the rights of defense
obviously taking all the
necessary precautions on excursions
sensitive elements but I will add that
it is something that is already the case
in most European countries
that she has something that is
necessary to ensure the proper
defense development and therefore
this strength of my amendment thank you
thank you always the same on 1320
opportunity to strengthen human rights
defense and adversarial and
actually it just said France
is one of the only European countries in
in which in which the citizens put
in question knows nothing about the file which
accuses him that he is taken what he is
made a fair and constrained defense
often the lawyer asked his client
to keep silent in custody
so they have to give the suspect and
his lawyer access to the file but the
audition custody bag
free
THANKS
thank you with the commissions on these three
amendment
and you were kind enough to
some of our eyebrows that comes from the
NBC
good openness to the contradictory
course
the municipality already made great progress and
the Keeper of the Seals is rather upbeat
on this question it seems to me
good I think that to guarantee the
efficiency today between the balance
between the effectiveness of the investigations
secret of the investigation the secret of
the investigation you know is something
who may have disappeared in our country from
France and the right of defense i
think it's best to stick with it
what does the withdraw 77-2 offer today
access to the file from the start of
the investigation on the surface this must
remain in the hands of the first prosecutor
first time then
the automatic opening takes place in
a second time as planned in the 5
of 5 of 77-2 so I remind you that
first appearance and generally
made as part of a presentation
immediately after the war of view the
proposal therefore you do and therefore not
achievable in in fact in
reality we agree since it is
In
but
the three of the defense are not
obviously crazy manga you have it
called Mr. jordanof called him back the
no one can keep silent
the lawyer if he is present will have everything
leisure to access the file therefore for life
unfavorable
[Music]
because for example on the
transcription of listening
phone we say you don't
transcribe only what is useful to the
manifestation of the truth and sometimes I
the judicial reminder in particular there is
truths plural I don't think I I
think it's going a bit far to
the moment
that this year a bit far for the
moment i want
please this is therefore i am
unfavorable to abandonment but
I think we'll get there and
Europe will no doubt understand us
European or those which depend on a
Council of Europe Convention follow
my look so here it is but we can see well
that it is not absolute firmness
thank you madam to the president sir
minister
the amendment which the amendments which have
been presented are of interest to
from the moment we want to know
why we are implicated afterwards in
the practice on who will weigh
the initiative of the initiative of choice
parts because it's going to be the
route is it going to be the country
so we already know who there is going to be
work overload is for these two
essential elements of the investigation
preliminary then and there I come back to
the amendment that was rejected outright
the time concerning the shortening
of the time limit for the preliminary investigation and there
I respond to our colleague Hunter
better than it is because a survey
preliminary has not been completed in
the six months or in the year that she goes
go to the trash we the idea is
of
time limit reaches year automatically
the public prosecutor's office to take the liquidator's
productive and referral to a judge
of instruction and there the contradictory
is already respected in the making of
knowledge by him who is put in
causes the reasons for his challenge
the last points so that things
be very clear between us in the case
of judicial information from the
when there is a commission
rogatory in legal practitioners
who are on this show we
knows very well that the investigating judge
can keep some
elements of these investigations before the
disclose to the party by payment
official at the of these parts at the
procedure so we don't give it back I
would say of an ideal scheme which is
maybe done in binary cable which
would allow access to certain parts
and already effectively within the framework of
judicial information since I
so repeat the commission to the cake
is not retained in full
parties still do not have access to
parts while the investigating judge him
he speaks the contact that he goes
investigators we can already start with
give it its elements and forge its
inner conviction
just to say we're sorry
this opinion against this amendment
by the way maybe sir keep it
unless you were a criminal lawyer
maybe you wouldn't have everything
make the same look but don't care about me
I think it's a shame to tell me tells me
my neighbor
what matters to us is this
legal defense case
contradictory whichever is better
established possible so we agree
parts that could be problematic
for the proper conduct of the investigation are
anyway withdraw we are talking about
justice of conscience and as when
we speak of a call for calm or as when
they say there is no love and who has
proofs of love I think that
more than we think one way
structural all the same around the
questions of organization of justice
we must try to make sure
always have in our mind it was
balance, including in terms of
I find a little
thank you i will voice it
presently identical I received a
unfavorable opinion of the commission and the
government that is for
who against it is not adopted madam
Carroi le 185
thank you Madam
Please
[Laughs]
strengthen the rights of defense and
win contract still in the
framework of the preliminary investigation in
giving the opportunity to present
observations of requests for acts and
requests in units indeed there are
today very few windows of
contradictory in the investigation
preliminary and for that imbalance
considerably the procedure of at
detriment to the rights of the defense
presents a world therefore proposes to give
the possibility for the subject and his lawyer
to be able to submit requests for acts
public prosecutor during
that she preliminary and opinion
potential and his lawyer to have access
in the file in the event of refusal an appeal
must be provided with the righteous of the
freedoms from detention with an appeal
possible in front of the chamber of
instruction and it also allows
give suspects and
his lawyer will present you with requests
of nullity of act and before the JFD and a
possible appeal always before the
instructure room away from
constitute an obstacle to
simplification of procedures
mechanism would allow train
necessary rebalancing of the rights of
the defense to avoid driving until
judging face of infrastructure
obviously wrong procedures
directed or in which acts
discharge or checks
essentials have not been accomplished
so it's really in this sense that
I drop off at some point
thank you Mr rapporteur with the
commission
we understand the concerns
today the 4 of 77-2 he specifies that
the prosecutor if the prosecutor refuses
forgiven an act of asking for the decision
challenged before the Attorney General
is okay it's the it's at the 4 of the
77-12 therefore the possibility of requesting a
act already exists and the possibility of
lodge an appeal against a refusal to
to do this act also existed therefore a
request for retirement
of the government
I fully understand the sound of
your amendment
judges of the freedoms of detention who
is not seized your body said nothing
him an appeal before the Chamber of
the instruction is a modifier
totally part of the investigation
preliminary to the same besides the role
of the freedom game of detention and
the chamber of instruction and in these
conditions I ask you to withdraw
your amendment where I will be forced
to tell you that I am against it
I fully understand these
amendments
we have to be careful we had
in a law of recent sir
reference 24 december 21 story we didn't
no reloading yet
precise on it
struck a perfect balance
coherent a balance that allowed
parties to obtain investigative material
if the public prosecutor
reconsidered as necessary or
after elements
deprivation of liberty or something so he
there is a search hearing or the other
item after a certain time
to be informed of what is in the
procedure from there work
keep working thank you thank you
to tell me what I want to say
next to that with an obviously if
we're just going there
elements that are already totally
integrate me what I fear above
it's all a form of delaying measure
during during investigations
that is to say, we can completely
obtain or request documents and
integrate an appeal procedure and
attitude that actually makes us live
much of the capacity
investigation of our police services
of gendarmerie of its meaning let's be
vigilant we are still in a
random system one that says you and not
still in an adversarial system even
if the mornings of contradictory and the
contradictory must have a certain
number of limits because otherwise
public order in France will have a hard time
to be continued to be respectful in all
case thank you madam
it's a pity Madam President
a conclusion is made between the
items that are already in the survey
No longer have peace on the base
investigations do not ask for the
public prosecutor to the police
and on requests i.e. y
including the persons implicated who
can request actions
of investigation aimed at clearing them
or so or in any case to attenuate the
responsibility of the one who is put in
Cause you did a procedure
to be able to access the file
it's one thing and so much the better and I have
been favorable so if I think he
must go further as we have
do the fact let's do the
demonstration in the amendment
previous but here it is the question of
requests
how many times have I heard from lawyers
penalists even when they have become
ministers and explain that things
could have been avoided at the hearing if
you were purged at the time of the stadium
of the survey, which normally does
in the instruction and what is not
possible in preliminary head
since there it is once again good
want district attorneys
and then when you said that there is a
recourse that is provided for in the general park
yeah yeah yeah it's true it's
formally true but I think everything
criminal lawyer from this country has already
appeal to the
attorney general who succeeds
almost never and therefore where we are
supposed to have something contradictory or
person in your power to pay
items in the Files requested from
additional elements here you are
say because you understand it must
be secret but that has nothing to do with
the secret blanquette or with the feet to
from the moment it becomes nurturing
the file has as many elements in
more that allow in the end to whom at the
magistrate in the formation of the judgment
to be independent of first a
informed judgment and not to be obliged
to bring coins when
the hearing which is where it is painful for
everyone for the opposing party
for the formation of judgment etc so
it is good administration of the
justice the proposal that is made here
and delaying tactic of what not what
you who bother you in the end is
that the judge of the freedoms of detention
which was not too encroaching on the
republic poker issues
and that it end up being a plus of
the investigation I know the disagreement dear
colleagues as such do not
some anti-goris that didn't jump him
even if I know that you taste little
group that we owe that we
represent i will never do that to you
front master the procedure that
rest assured you are a great
professional in the matter so we
find exchange I would say serenely
and the amendment that has been tabled
really reminds one who turns
perpetually around the bush and I
always come back to the problem of
the duration of the preliminary investigation but
there what the CNB yet the scene I there
am a little tied down by protection
that I continue to exercise in fact we
lead to the creation of a monster
legal to what extent to what
extent the Geld would become jurisdiction
of the shovel a decision of refusal of act
opposed by a judge
instructor but to prosecutor of the
Republic and then go to the
chamber of instruction while
the instruction as such does not exist
not yet really for me really there
solution and and Mr. the guardian of
seals it really is a foot call
very strong
reduce the legal time of the investigation
preliminary with judges
instruction
shade in number to be able to allow
the opening of taxes and there the
contradictory is respected and we
will go within the classic framework of the
criminal procedure I make a request
of act to my judge my judge refuses it
I will contest his refusal before the
room of the structure but I believe
really that the question of the deadline
animates all and in addition we would breastfeed the
work of prosecutors who, moreover,
who must set to music the
penal policy the pain meant
there are your circulars good really I
really think we're all in agreement
to say it's too long having
examining magistrates in number and
open the info to allow the
rights of defense be respected thank you
Madam
I will withdraw the amendment but
obviously the goal is to and
shorten the time of
household indetriment and to allow
suspect of having a real one
right of defense therefore subject to reservation
also a commitment of more than
celebrities maybe over
power obviously I withdraw it thank you
then he is taken over by the group
sensation
of the government which is for
concerning access to the files of a
person who has been the subject of
search or sight card and
reduce this period from 1 year to 6 months
in particular to make it
identical to that provided for in article
82-2 of the Code of Criminal Procedure which is
sets a deadline of 6 months to be able to
challenge you or request the cancellation of
this type of act contained the object of these
provisions and identity of deadlines
seems more consistent
a little different in the in the frame
of 802-2 the person can claim the
provision not of the file
as you say but alone but the
only parts of the proceedings will be
bearing the search that disputes i
think we should keep
two different things and therefore life
unfavorable we are not at all on the
same procedure to which they complement each other
more relevant to
will advise thank you Minister had
of the government
thank you madam martin
thank you we can once again and I
don't take it back
my earlier arguments but I
think it is fundamental democratic
guarantee in law guarantee the means of
own defense so that this
period is actually shortened there
so it's not just a question
technique is to know if yes or
no we want to approach others
standards that further guarantee the
rights of defense
thank you i will take a moment of course
an unfavorable opinion from the committee
government that is for
who against
we are still a president shirt
in the same state of mind on the
rights of defense and adversarial proceedings
same spirit as amendment 26 that we
we talked and we beat
presently so here we are on a
fallback amendment so we would have a
6 month misdemeanor
which is not immediate which is less
that the delay of one year here we are
allows to have a middle voice in all
case a proposal that would allow
to move forward without shaking things up
basically and that would leave
I always use the expression of
Minister one step ahead
to some here
thank you sir
to strenghten
to reverse you
plaintiff to prepare his defense in this
case it seems to me that things are not going well
your unfavorable life really I I had to
hard to understand with exactly the
mechanism what you suggest
thank you minister
ment 27 that holds the lives of the women of
the Commission
Solignac thank you Madam President for
present 329
us coming
move under witness regime
witnessed we believe that this
possibility
especially since in the case of cash it
it is also about strengthening the rights of
his witnesses assisted this provision
presupposes, however, setting a deadline which
would impose itself on the judge to respond to
this request in committee sir
minister you are new you were
said and declared in favor framed on
appeal period for persons in
detention and for the reasons that can be
obviously understand about
those who are detained and
therefore this subscription offers a period of
one month maximum from the date of
on remand and the amendment
following the 765 takes it to two months but
if you allow me since the occasion
to give them to me in one word, madam
President Mr. Minister you
you mentioned earlier the situation
clerks and you had words
rather encouraging towards them even if
you made it clear that you
couldn't fit anymore in the
detail I just wanted to clarify
that the pay increase
that you mentioned of the order of 12%
actually concerns the IFC the indemnity of
function not and not the grid
index it was party obviously is not
not taken into account in the same way
in particular the calculation of the pension of
base
the expectations of the clerks is indeed the
index grid I remind you that I am
done feet and recruited today 40
euros as soon as possible thank you for them
thank you then Mr rapporteur on these
two amendments of 300 meters I will
invites you to remove the
500 765 what you have the
764 after which is better 10 years so I
invites you to withdraw it for the benefit of the
thank you minister
thank you thank you Madam President this is
the same opinion as the one I come from
to express, Mr. Rapporteur, for
exactly the same reasons
about the clerks since you
ask the question and thank you for being
you are right by the way that I had
worries about making things better and that
you currently have it was rather
reassuring that the accuracy certainly the
precision you just made is
useful but it still represents on
the sheet of P300 euros
increase since I became a minister
and the detail
I would like the sizes in cents ready
There
tomorrow if you want I take advantage I
benefit Madam President for a second
that since I have the floor for you
say that people people from the ultra
left entered the court
judiciary of Lyon
of these men wore a t-shirt
since he claimed on his t-shirt I
quoted
nickel to the police yes they started
sing what you say everyday
i.e. he hates the police i
I want to have I want to have I want
have this moment i want to know i want
know that at this moment
I wanna know this moment keep it on
the floor if you wish to speak
I'll give it to you
that to the word
keep him to his word
Monsieur Hervé on you
a thought and I think this time
here almost common I say almost for
the magistrates
the clerks
administrative staff lawyers
are doubts who have had and who have seen
disembark our friends your friends not the
mine your friends
to mess with this audience like
sometimes we mess around other places
democratic equally democratic
also thank you
thank you sir
their support trout here
there were 28 at the moment and there thank you
here thank you and then I think that all
the national presentation except that the
barrier that day to me to have
this republican collective thought
for our magistrates thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
you withdraw the amendments
are removed
the minister if it's a game
the Assembly as a whole or just
part of the hemicycle but
divert provoke a belter
like that to implicate colleagues
deputies those who would have destroyed
no tweets i know you did
no means of coercion on the
government I agree but I think
that a solemn reminder to the government
to the government and to our debates would be
welcome, I also remind you that
the fact that we must focus on the
question in the belly of the moment how
applies to any speaker in
the hemicycle and not just on its own
deputies on these benches but also to
members of the government it is a
moreover maneuver with extremely
problem on the part of the neighborhood and
I could even accuse him of not
having talked about the other jurisdictions that
have been vandalized and for which
we provide support during
all the municipalities of France
are still not for the rampage of
courts Minister then I
go I go
of section 70
which invites not to put in
personal cause or interpellation
of another Member or of addresses to one or
insults several of his colleagues
household provocation i think we
we will all have an interest in respecting this
article 70 paragraph 3
but
parliamentarian deputy as government
the rules apply to everyone
applies within the scope of the issue
Madam President another call to the
settlement
and thank you for calling
our rules if your securities also
of politics 77 i'm going to do
stand this about we have a lot
heard the words it's the
Concorde these last days and I think
that it is a pity
to instrumentalize this moment then
that precisely we could have depended on it
of magistrates in expenditure of courts
express our solidarity with a
concordeur there are times when it is necessary
know how to get out of political postures
to have a little height sir
minister
especially since you can't
you can't blame us
to have today to have
complacency
of the Republic a whole part of these
elected and elected who today
defend the rights of the French
really put a minister in the
in the moment that you we live in
the moment we live
it's not serious thank you ma'am
President
Mr. Gosselin
in reality no one leads to colleagues
insubordinate to the bands of the Republic by
the ambiguity of your remarks but dear
Insou colleagues
put guilty silences it's you
who you turn on
republic i'm sorry
[Applause]
I'm sorry
[Laughs]
[Applause]
who says that the speaker must not
deviate from the question otherwise the
presidents call that's what I
am doing now your
remind Madam President not the
president don't worry and I wanted
so to repeat what I said because
I believe it is to share widely
on the thoughts here with the the amendment
it is to inform
the share of tennis demand under review
it is true that today the parties
civilians are not informed at all
they cannot comment
before the judge's decision
of instruction and therefore he
there is no integrating them
observations or observations it is
the observations speaking of the game
civilian so that is the subject of this
amendment to allow it thank you
Mr Rapporteur
facing the office of the investigating judge
civil party does not have to know and
to judge, moreover, whether the person is
assisted
to do this job for life
unfavorable
thank you minister
I was just starting out that was the part
many civil rights during
the instruction but it's very good as
that however does not drive the action
public they review is a decision
and and what will commandment is adopted
basically you give the shy part
the same rights and the same
prerogatives than those belonging
exclusively produce in the
Republic and from my point of view we
modifies balances of the procedure
criminal way
unfavorable to the amendment you
carry
thank you i will put in the wood
amendment 29 who received the video
in favor of the commission and the
government that is for
on this subject which has been raised
regarding the anemia under examination
actually currently in case of
application for review
of article 801 the judge must
decide within one month
lack of what good we call him in front
destruction chamber is possible
in application of the provisions
general provisions of Article 82 1 and therefore
it's a moment etc we propose to
provide that the provisions apply
of Article 80 which provides for a response
within a month he calls
possible if not precisely in front of the
chamber of instruction because precisely what
delay and it's him usually
applicable to requests made for
train forgiveness during instruction
thank you mr rapper
the one month deadline seems appropriate to me.
and your amendment is better said
since it concerns the assisted witness and
THE
nonsense no
excuse me i was on an amendment
then I'll think about it and so
It's good
he is welcome a month to status on the
exam resignation request
it seems to me she is in the right direction
I remind you that one of the objectives
to sign these texts these texts he
wanted to settle is to reduce the
civil court delays by two
thank you sir bernalicis
THANKS
we are with your favorable group
especially us too too but I
would like to attract the tension of the
representation that we will vote at
an amendment when there was no
of impact studies I would say that we
let's all agree on what we
is doing
I just want to warn everyone and
I am for big words too we
will vote
which received a favorable opinion from
rapporteur and government supporter
who is for whom against it is adopted
a moment 294
I don't know if it was cracked
of 830 Mr Rapporteur
thank you sir favorable minister i
put three children
of coherence it is thus forbidden
Monsieur will report it unfavorably
Minister, I'm going to show
with a guest at the government who is
for who
is not adopted the 284 Mr. Plaza
the 34
thank you madam president
the President of the Bar to a certain number of
can you know he already has the
possibility therefore of prohibiting
prevent transcriptions
documents or objects in a cabinet
and there it is possibly for him
to challenge the transcripts
have known the fact already
so it is ultimately an extension of
what is being done today for
documents or objects when there are
searches in the context of a cabinet
of a lawyer
thank you sir
My president of referred to in article 100 does not
don't talk about transcriptions but
directly from the interception line
from a line of a lawyer this is the case
we decide to wiretap a
telephone line then the
provisions for the reconstruction of
Cannabis exchanges with a lawyer
relating to the exercise of the rights of the
defense and covered by secrecy
defense and defense professional
advice with its provided for in article without
shoot 5 let's go already brings
guaranteed since barely overnight
exchanges with a lawyer within the framework
rights of defense cannot cannot
can't be can't be sweat
it's written in black on white and the
exchanges captured by a school
telephone cannot be transcribed
hardly any levels so i can't see
good because we could challenge the
chairman since the ban is
clearly posed therefore unfavorable for life
but i think that indeed
the amendment is fully satisfied
THANKS
you remove it
the identical amendments are withdrawn
of 35 Mr. Gosselin
referring to article 5 of the Code of
criminal procedure it is
to prohibit
and the intersection and the record
exchanges between a lawyer and his
customer
indeed it is a question of ensuring the secrecy
professional article 100 looks like 5 of the
criminal procedure club provide
indeed that the exchanges between a
lawyer and his client cannot be
transcribed it is a question of avoiding that it
can be intercepted and therefore add
terms intercepted and recorded
tense
the 511 Mr. Castellani
Yes thanks
of the previous amendments it is
proposed in this amendment of our
colleague aquaviv it is proposed
to prohibit the recording
capture and interception of
conversations between a lawyer and his
customer thank you
thank you opinion of the commission on these
identical amendments
take it point by point because that
deserves a little explanation then
prohibition of any interception
principle it is laid down in Article 100 of the
blow of the CPP no interception can
relate to a line dependent on the
lawyer's office or home
well there are unless there are
plausible reasons to suspect it I
I'm not going to go into detail about
the ban then
recording then what you
propose seems a bit complicated to me and
not very operational in reality for example
if a man is bugged a man
Here is a man or a woman being bugged
woman obviously and that he calls his
lawyer how do you want us
know immediately that he is
to call him it will not be possible
SO
I don't see how we can put
place this system good in addition there are
guarantees we talked about it earlier
on the blood
I think the blood will smell it 5
and will feel it 7 that I come from you
quickly expose
already offers Ford warranties
on the other hand we share your
concern and I allow you to
remember in this regard that during the
on the subject of sound systems which
will come just now we have in
committee adopted an amendment which has a
strong amendment that goes in the direction
of the protection of secrecy and who will
in the in this sense there it is of
clearly reaffirm the prohibition of
any transcript of exchanges with
a lawyer in the law of the
defense is the first point of
reaffirm the protection of certain
places, in particular offices
of lawyers if exchanges are captured and
the transcript will also be
forbidden then made again and we
added it in committee they
provide for the destruction of
records so we really
advanced on the sound system by putting a
number of devices
additional
thank you minister
Thank you, Madam President, Mr.
Deputy Gosselin if you remember
when we discussed here the law of 22
December 2021 we had mentioned the
possibility
to copy what the Americans are doing
that is, American lawyers
list the phones that are
likely to use personal line
cabinet etc and as soon as one of these
numbers is on sorry that's the term
technique is not the right one cuts
it's not feasible that we can't do it
make and therefore the amendment that you
therefore propose this is the reason for
which we were told we can't and
we cannot transcribe
and we have together besides I say
restore a professional secrecy which
was but totally delicious
not to say non-existent
I totally agree with your opinion
but what do you want
wish I hear that not only
of course we can't transcribe that
it's already in the marble of the text but
that we can't hear but the